two
hello hello
h3tb
2022
at 202 o'clock
what does it mean
oh
it tastes like beef jerky
[Music]
i gotta do my own voiceover of that
is it not oh it's off the rails right
right right it's all melding together
guys
let's be honest but welcome everybody to
the show
we've got a great show here for a change
unlike all the other episodes
sponsored by harry's razor babble and
stamps.com
action pack action-packed episode
uh
we actually have our first
i'm gonna say first but our first
on-field segment
using our cutting-edge new technology
cutting edge
we have uh
love
as our swedish correspondent here
heading over to ikea
for the first international ikea world
cup
he is going to be performing a series of
of swedish
feats for you all
live from ikea that's right
he is going to be performing
five major categories fika time
furniture friend
fred is good again forever
fred exim
i have no idea how to say that
for life
uh there's all kinds of swedish stuff
we'll get into that i think they're
they're on their way they're getting
ready they are they are uh setting up in
front of the ikea right as we speak i'm
i'm watching their video feed from my uh
from my command and to be clear we do
not have permission to film this or is a
chance we'll be shut down i think
there's a
fairly high likelihood i would say 95
yeah well once they see love's outfit
right he we sam has decked him do we
have a photo or anything
in us in the custom ikea fit we've made
for him
what does that sound i'm actually being
told that uh they're ready
okay let's let's just get right into the
well also today we have planned you guys
know that uh
wow there's been some juicy drama
developments we'll get into after this
segment
david made a whole podcast essentially i
would say blaming jeff for the accident
and jeff made a response video and i've
watched them all we're going to get into
that but first we've got correspondence
foo we got feet on the ground here so
why don't we say hello
to our our swedish
competitor
there is love
now
love
how does it feel
oh you know it feels like home i'm
finally at ikea i haven't
outside of sweden
any any time you know so i'm here to
shake the ikea out i'm here to make sure
it's swedish enough that it doesn't
hasn't lost its swedish you know essence
and i'm also supposed to do some uh
challenges some swedish challenges so
yeah it's awesome
what's the technology we've gotten dan
that's enabled us to go on because the
last time we did this was love at the
free brittany which technically was a
disaster
yeah oh sorry ab yes uh that was
definitely a disaster um yeah uh we've
set up with a with a cellular pack now
and so uh you know we have an actual
camera you're gonna have to mute his mic
when he's not talking because that [ __ ]
is wild yeah you got that zach yeah
thank you um yeah so we have a cellular
backpack uh you know what like the irl
streamers do when they're wandering
around vegas harassing people and stuff
um camera and professional cameras like
your phone not my phone and me and
olivia sharon airpods that was nobody's
fault by the way it was just very well
it was last minute we decided like 20
minutes before to go do it it was i mean
it was a fantastic segment but now if we
can go so cameron is with love is that
right he's right he's the man behind the
man behind the cam behind the cam uh
the dynamic duo
whoa
oh okay so love why don't you show off
this custom fit here
yeah so
we got some swedish swedish custom fit
here the drip is real the swedish drip
is real so let's start off with a
swedish fika ikea hat
this is a bucket hat straight from
sweden of course made from authentic
ikea bags
like pure ikea bags
completely made of ikea bags and then we
got this amazing sweater that by the way
sam has made herself super cool zoom out
a little bit cameron let me get it let
me let me see the whole
zoom out a little bit yeah
and then the boots let me see the tims
and the thames finally
you know i feel like vetements could
sell that for a thousand bucks
absolutely no the the shoes are really
what puts it over the top damn you made
all that
sam holy crap how do you even do that
that's impressive
you should be next door at teddy fresh
forget this
this show
your talents are wasted here
ethan i heard you said
can anyone hear me right now yes
[Music]
okay so i heard you said that we don't
have permission that's actually not
right i have here a message from the
king of sweden uh you see here it's all
completely authentic he's completely
real his sign here
and this is not a crime
to
to print something like this out from
the internet this is actually completely
legal absolutely it says right here that
we have uh complete and full permission
to do whatever we want in ikea
wow okay great this is trump's
uh american law
yeah yeah that's right all right so
american law this is above american law
all right so we're gonna go in there
we're not gonna try too much trouble we
hopefully we won't have to bust out the
letter from the king yeah
so let me lay out the competition rules
first love
the first competition is going to be
fika time love is going to have to eat
eight meatballs in one minute
the second one is furniture friend love
is gonna have to help one customer
uh select furniture to purchase you know
he can translate the swedish titles he's
sweetest so obviously he can
he has insight that other people don't
i don't know what this says love what is
the third one fred is fred
fred has gizms forever
yeah you almost right it's freya dog's
miss felix miss is a swedish tradition
of course on the friday you like kind of
kick back relax it's friday cozy time
with the family with the girlfriend with
anyone you like
you sit back you get some snacks you get
some drinks and you just have a nice
time on the friday you know so we're
doing freddy's gizm forever love
convinces someone to fret his gizm with
him
on the couch on one of the couches there
oh my god
that should be easy
at what can we show that on youtube two
dudes on a couch or two people on the
couch i think so once they keep their
clothes on yeah mid-summer sma
dora
uh to celebrate the traditional holiday
of sweden love will find a pole to dance
around and sing traditional sma
rodona a song
okay
and the baltic builder select a small
shelf or cabinet
and level have to assemble it before the
end of the podcast wow
so at my my hunches we're going to be
checking in periodically with the guys
there
if you can complete every task before
the show is over or before you get
kicked out
you will be crowned more likely the fika
king
fika king my friend
uh what is joel bach i'm very excited we
can talk about that
uh what is this jewel box so
what's the context here dan
i added that cause love was just telling
me about this and i thought it was
pretty funny so we're gonna burn down
this goat
you guys build a giant goat of hay and
then burn it down
so
i guess we'll have to do that so you're
gonna have to burn
you're gonna have to set something on
fire in ikea uh for this uh for this
category no no no no
no no no no burning guys okay
all right so so uh check back in with us
when you're ready
why don't you start with fika time and
uh and uh check back in with us when
you're ready to report okay
i'll i'll be back and i'll be back with
a plate of the finest meatballs in the
world
sounds good buddy see you then
[Applause]
see you all right good luck guys
well
their journey begins and we'll see
yeah uh it's that audio please thank you
yeah
can still hear it
yeah i have it down
i can still hear them
okay
i don't know why
so
you can still hear them
so uh what a action there you go you got
it uh action-packed
show here today
i don't know how long they're i don't
know how much they lock down the ikeas
here we'll have to see i mean
i think they'll get off the meatballs
that's simple enough you go and buy some
meatballs no problem there
but you never know
cam is equipped with a camera
is the is the streamer sim card
some kind of crazy looking backpack or
is it discreet
it's pretty discreet i have it all
packed up in a way that it just looks
like a normal backpack uh other than
the uh you know cable with the camera
sticking out of the side of it i think
the bigger problem is probably the ikea
outfit um well who says you can't wear
an ikea outfit
i don't think there's any explicit rule
but i don't know if i was a security
guard working at the front of an ikea
and a guy
walked in and looking like that
i would probably walk over and just see
what see what's going on yeah well you
will you you might do that i might do
that because you are a uh
who is a narc narc yeah yeah you're
exactly you're uh you try you work too
hard but
all right you know we were talking a lot
about tai lopez
oh um actually quick update um because i
have uh a phone link to them and i'm
hearing in the background they're
already being yelled at by an ikea
employee we'll pull it up
okay we have a lot of people who try to
come in
[Music]
we're not going to record anybody else
we're just going to record our
experiences so they're already being
stopped
before getting to the door
i just want to say
i said put on the outfit inside because
the outfit is the dead giveaway that
you're up to shenanigans but
[Music]
the camera is in the shopping cart
they're being yelled at by the security
guard they didn't even make it halfway
to the front door
[Music]
live from ikea parking lot
um
turbulence already
oh i had a few love can you hear me
what's going on there
they're they're still talking with the
ladies
i heard her say i can get my manager
oh
this is already being escalated we just
want meatballs folks
we only want meatballs love what's going
on there
boots on the ground
the first international ikea world cup
is already in jeopardy
okay we'll have to check back with them
um at another time but wow
already on shaky ground i hear they're
talking to them or they're asking to
speak to the manager so
all right well oh
wow tragedy already striking this
wonderful competition i was worried
about this because a few years ago there
was a lot of youtubers doing like
24-hour challenges in ikea like since
that moment
i just want to buy meatballs just like
just tell them we're just here for the
meat i feel like it's great it's great
uh advertisement for the brewery you
should be paying us for this to be
honest ikea drip it's like what more do
you want
all right well let's move on and
check back in with them you know garyvee
i like talking about garyvee we gave tai
lopez a lot of [ __ ] for his uh
his nfts
but you know who's the originator of
this tai lopez 100 just ripped off gary
vee i didn't realize uh he just totally
ripped him off
i guess the difference is that garyvee
is actually successful doesn't make it
any less
knowledge pathetic though and weird how
yeah he's selling off go courtside with
me courtside cat
for a hundred ethereum
[Music]
now why
what is that like 250 000 bucks more
three hundred thousand
now guys
i ask you what is wrong with this world
[Music]
i ask you
a mentor meeting
this other one mentor meeting
mongoose oh jesus you guys
who wants to lose some money today
exactly
wait was that tai lopez that was tai
lopez who wants to lose some money today
is that what he says at his conferences
well that was that was a video dan found
it was uh
him uh talking on one of your mike's
very quiet
uh
for facetime in garyvee you can pay 35
ethereum
which has got to be around you know
almost a hundred thousand dollars just
to face to own this facetime
fly
95k
95k
what the [ __ ]
i can't get over this look at this proud
this kid he's so proud of his [ __ ]
fly
shame on whoever bought this
golly i'll go out i'll just buy a
self-help book and read you quotes out
of it too for a hundred thousand dollars
you know what i mean
so what let's see how pathetic this kid
jam session snail
you want to jam with gary vee
for 80 grand
i hate it who wants me to take their
money
[Laughter]
you can go wine shopping with gary vee
shadow me again i love the intern one
that's my favorite
you can get coffee for me
and uh
for twenty
fifty thousand dollars so
this whole movement what do you think i
mean ab i'm gonna ask for thoughts here
on this one what do you think
maybe thoughts
oh he's drinking conveniently well you
don't have to accept a long drink bro
just put the drink down i gotta ask you
are you drinking sorry i'm really
drinking
thirsty
gonna save you bro
what's going on i was checking on love
hashtag free love
gary v yeah that's expensive
i wouldn't pay that much to facetime you
yes you would
play poker with me
for 25 000
work out with me
don't you think it's corny to be selling
it's like he really values himself that
high that he thinks
isn't that just a little icky to be like
come work out with me for 25 000
i just bro come on these are your fans
these are your people
he's so cool why do you need to get paid
like has anybody bought this so a lot of
them are one of one and they have yeah
all of them have sales i mean it says
last sale so yeah
wow yeah they are selling
definitely
wait facetime five is it really just
five minute face time
five minute face time
for how much
last sale was four eighth so ten grand
almost
twelve thousand dollars twelve thousand
dollars for a five minute face time bro
wow he's just doing cameos now basically
that's the glorified camera i heard you
can facetime a b or zach for like 20
bucks yeah
you better make you feel bro yeah my mom
does five minute cameos for people right
wow embarrassing
hey guys oh
guys i'm doing a competition for our
fans only
you can come spend five minutes with me
your idol
for a hundred thousand dollars
any minute over five will be charged to
your card we'll need your card ahead of
time to put it on file
you will be responsible for providing
transportation and cert food and stuff
like that
lacroix if you want to la croix during
our five-minute session that's gonna be
five dollars
we do offer refreshments as well
hamburgers and such twenty dollars it is
a very nice it's a good hamburger
you know
uh and it is only five minutes so come
prepared
you know
we book a lot of these for one day so we
can't go over the time limit so just
remember
five minutes is all you get
currently going for a hundred thousand
dollars
and i love my fans i mean this is why we
do it right
i love my fans
get in line to hang out with me for five
minutes how much would a fan have to pay
to work out with you
oh well you know that's an exclusive
experience because i don't really work
out right
oh that'd be i don't know 250
and my working sessions are
five minutes long so right
bring your own weights obviously you
will not you you can't use my equipment
just for sanitary purposes yeah so
you're gonna have to bring your own
equipment or you can just watch well for
coveted reasons too you probably
shouldn't even be in the same room
no it'll be face time yeah yeah it'll be
a facetime it's time workout yeah just
cause i love my fans i love my fans
spend a hundred thousand dollars for
five minutes with me i love my fans
oh
come sit courtside with me for a million
bucks
you gotta get a whole season of
quartzite tickets for that and then
maybe while you're like scary i really
want to ask you
the game
sorry about my friend he's so [ __ ]
rude
once a day genuinely sit there for five
minutes and make pretend one of them got
shot in the face i will do a special
mediation a meditation session where we
both
simultaneously imagine our family
members being shot in the face
half a million bucks
therapy will be provided uh separately
by your own cost
therapists will not be provided
i don't know man these guys are all
scammers
[Music]
huh
oh we have a loving cam update they seem
to be getting uh yelled at okay roll it
up
all right guys
oh really
i thought that was a coffin first in the
booth so love and cam are being
confronted by what looks like a security
guard there's people in there who
usually like for next time if you guys
do they bring their like they bring in
their own bag like these blueberries
they are
still not even close to the entrance
here
here's some laughter between them so
maybe it's you know
love can i can i can love hear me
there's people who do it all the time
they might have taken out the ear pieces
to uh when they're like with like let's
hear it be like super
incarcerated
[Applause]
don't wear the jacket up to the you got
to put that
was was i mean it was a beautiful shot
don't get me wrong yeah we had the
lovely hat introduction they had to do
it that way i agree with ian and i
scouted the place yesterday and we gave
them very
explicit instructions what to do what
not to do and uh i guess they didn't
follow them
you see there's some advantages to just
being on an iphone and some airpods oh
absolutely you can do anything there
yeah
well it's just again when you're walking
in the front entrance right decked out
listen it's part of the competition
you're gonna draw some attention love
couldn't even put his hands down all the
way because the jacket was really stiff
so very noisy too they'll hear him
coming ian what did you say and they're
leaving right now they seem to be
leaving
oh oh hold up get the camera all right
wow oh so love
is in the parking lot he's out of his
ikea outfit
yeah what's happening love yeah can you
elect the car
we're gonna
we're gonna go back in buy some stuff
obviously we're gonna leave our
video equipment out here in the or
in the car you know
and we'll go back in and see if we can
find anything to buy for the last
challenge at the very least i'm going to
buy some i'm going to buy some meatballs
for myself too and then some swedish
caddy and then we're going to head out
so did you present them the letter from
the king loved
you know they they seemed really mad
i
i i don't think it was a you know
the right moment to do that
well it is the with the full authority
of the of the sovereign king of sweden
that yeah you should probably ask for
the manager to come back yeah did you
not speak to a manager about that
i'm gonna bring it bring it back in and
present oh we did talk to a manager hey
can you hear me yeah we did talk to a
manager uh one of the employees was a
fan of the show and took a picture with
us but unfortunately
the manager said no no no you guys
couldn't work that yeah
the employee the uh
they said no no no we
we uh we don't yeah the employees here
are very cool you know they said uh next
time you should hide it this and this
way yeah so we got some tips for the
next time you know
well that's nice of them so far
we are uh the international
ikea competition is not going exactly as
planned but we will check back in with
them when we have some furniture and
meatballs on on hand yeah maybe they can
slam the meatballs in the back seat of
the car make sure to get eight meatballs
okay uh we can at least do a couple
categories here
okay thank you guys
thank you wow
what a shame
you know
who could have seen this coming a tragic
end to the first ever
ikea competition
wow
hey what's going on with eminem's
apparently they're pissing off
christians another big corporation
company making fun of our lord and
savior jesus christ there's nothing new
under the sun they love to mock jesus
and you know how i know that he's the
one true god because they never mock any
other god never hear them saying
anything about buddha never hear them
saying anything about allah it is always
jesus there's literally a dove ascending
right above his head right here in this
image it is disgusting it is blasphemy
but this is what they like to do you
want to know how i know that god is the
truth check this out this is what the
lord just revealed to me think about
when you are in the truth when it comes
to things that are going on in the world
right with the news what does the false
prophet media do scoffs at you makes fun
of you makes you think that you're wrong
right tells you that you're not in the
truth but really you are in the truth
and then when you're following the lies
they cheer you on and they're all for it
can we pull up this picture what is this
the green eminem has is ascending down
yeah i actually there's some info uh
right underneath it's actually an homage
to uh the packaging is an homage to this
album work el mal
queer um
oh it's an album cover
from 2018
uh from the band loving
el mal no it's uh it's rosalia
that's her name okay
so they made just like a little bit of a
meme on it
i have to assume it's like a
collaboration or something
okay
so eminem's just going to hell no here
we go
i mean
making fun of our lord and savior jesus
christ there's nothing new under the sun
they love to mock jesus and you know and
think your your level of mockery against
jesus is the bar is a little low there
lady
i mean it's just an eminem
you know
now if you want to hear someone mock
jesus all you gotta do is put on uh they
say podcast no of course not i would
never
all you gotta do is go to any uh
basically a church these days
where they hate gay people
they hate the trans people
they are full of lies a conspiracy
you know the only blasphemy happening is
in church itself
there's a link to where you can buy it
online by the way here it is
i mean it's a little weird i'll admit on
eminem's part like i get it's the card
it says it says eminem is celebrating a
popular album covers of influential
artists in a limited edition pack so
there's like this is an ongoing series
an ongoing series yes i mean if it was
like a picture of jesus like begging for
his life on the cross like super graphic
and stuff like that and renouncing he's
like please i renounce it i'm not the
son of god just spare me please like
i'll be like okay that's a bit far
eminem
speared to
death or maybe jesus engaged in some
kind of act of uh
love with another man that i would get
amen hallelujah
i mean i would think that would be
pretty epic but
that'll get okay well shout out to
eminem apparently blasphemy
here is david bowie okay i see
this is their david bowie one
okay there you go
vr gaming oh this is so funny man this
is one of those videos that i just love
this is perfect i was hoping you hadn't
but i figured i saw it on um i saw it on
my own feed
yo this is so good i uh oh my god okay
so
i don't understand i mute it
so like
we're gonna have to break this down okay
now
this is meant to be spinning okay yeah
and the whole machine
got thwarted by one of these little
metal
rope holders
it it it hits this thing and then the
machine tilts
spins itself off access
it's not fastened to the floor or
anything
i wonder if she just thought it was part
of the ride you know yeah
that's the 4d experience
[Laughter]
what a piece of [ __ ] dude isn't it
supposed to be fastened to the floor
it didn't take much to topple that that
really doesn't just this thing yeah it
turns the whole base
i mean it does it was like perfectly
positioned to do that too which yeah i
mean how was that the first person to
ride the damn thing it must have been
just imagine like you're filming it
right you're like this is gonna be
awesome when your friend just gets
blasted off the stage
oh man that's so funny vr is so stupid
you guys i'm sorry but it is
ugh i could it's just the best
oh and she's all like her feet are
fastened down her arms are fastened down
she can't move you just in for the ride
yeah the top problem is damn this ride
feels too real
there you have it yeah and your
technology is really coming along it's
really come a long way i knew that one
was gonna be a hit with you
um before we move on we're actually
already no 30 minutes yeah
no shot
every year is getting shorter it's my
day job never seem to have the time
let's watch one more this is machine
this guitar player exposes that machine
gun kelly when he's on stage playing his
uh
i fell in love with the emo girl is that
something popular by the way is that
like on the billboard charts or anything
i think it is it's definitely on the
tick tock part which usually means that
it is on youtube yeah sometimes people
use it ironically on things
with an emo girl well this guy's like
dude you're not even playing the guitar
he has the um
there's like a switch on the electric
guitar and when you put it down it just
cuts all input or output
here
today we've got an interesting new
guitar end machine gun kelly
signature schecter
this car is a pretty interesting feature
it's called a kill switch for those of
you who don't know
you flip this in the down position cuts
off all the volume making it completely
silent
that got me wondering
how does mgk use this in his live
performances let's go take a look
okay exhibit a
let's zoom in shall we
clearly in the down position here but
let's refer to mgk this is obviously
from a music video and people don't
really play in music videos so let's
find a live one shall we
surely it's up in a live photo right
right
okay exhibit b is definitely playing
here let's zoom in
oh no okay definitely still in the down
position dumb ass
surely there's some out there where it's
not like that right exhibit c come on
mgk don't let me down
dude oh
mgk do edited this and disproved it says
the audience okay let's go where's mgk
baby
wait the the chat is is rallying for mgk
um
we have a few watch mgk duet he
disproved okay pull it up he posted a
reply mentioning he was wrong i mean not
that he's playing like basic power
chords so
i don't think he's shredding or anything
unbelievable but let's let's get let's
hear his side you know
you looking for that he is one of the
most important artists of our time he is
and that would be this is a huge scandal
that he's not yeah to to his credit and
i haven't seen his response uh it's very
very possible and i [ __ ] hate this
guy
that he could have the kill switch
disabled it's very possible he just he
disabled it entirely possible all right
here we go this is big
mgk coming out with the
so i work here guitar center facts
enlarging interesting
[Music]
down it's on
his live performances
so he's saying
his is the opposite let's go take a look
okay
let's zoom in shall we sure
clearly
[Music]
oh dude he burned him he said i mustache
you
yo he's coming for his throat mgk is
savage wow
why you made this live a video i don't
think the guy at guitar center is
reverse engineering the guitar just in
defense of that guy
it's possible
that they're just different
for
produced and one was probably made
specifically for himself right slightly
different how it works
when i used to hang out with post
fender and like uh all these big guitar
people
they would just come by with like crazy
guitars for him right so
yeah i think you're right they would
just be like yo dude we got these crazy
new guitars checking them out
[Music]
i think you're right
i only played my guitar
you're wearing a liquid death hat i'm
also a part owner in that company so
you're promoting me while hey continue
going
he's annoying even when he's right he's
so annoying that's why i said it's
brutal they get [ __ ] owned by that
guy that's why he owns liquid death
that's not the like it's just water
uh yeah it's like canned water and that
also um
he doesn't he doesn't cody go own that
cody cole yeah
liquid death i think so
he's like part owner or something
i gotta say that's one of the dumbest
companies i've ever heard
they try to turn water into something
like metal
guys it's just water
it's really just canned water here
yeah uh
it looks like yeah kodiko does uh
at least
early investor or something yeah he has
some association with it
i can't is this really going to go
somewhere liquid death lands 75 million
more to expand the brand
okay there you go
when you can sell water for five bucks
per can you really [ __ ]
you really got us all good man
how do you raise 75 million dollars for
canned water
i guess it's just that that its
marketing is so
like viral and like
i think part of it is that it's so
stupid that
you remember it you know what i mean
yeah but what about dropping five bucks
for it
is it actually that expensive i don't
know but like
when you sell it like it's beer in a
nine pack i'm assuming
i'm assuming it's gotta cost like how
much does it cost for a let's see
uh
on amazon a 12 pack of tall boys
let's get [ __ ] up on liquid death
tonight bro
12 packs of 15 bucks on amazon uh so
actually you know that's probably like a
a dollar 30 per can they're real quick
that different things yeah people are
saying it's environmentally friendly
that's true i mean they don't use
plastic that's good that's plastic but
boxed water i also thought was so dumb
and it's actually not you know it's it's
environmentally friendly the box water
thing yeah i suppose it's better than
the plastic
maybe what uh what do i know
i'm sure that the
the aluminum manufacturing plant is
putting some metal in our ground water
yeah they're just i mean
yeah
less plastic so
i feel like the cardboard is probably
more environmentally friendly than the
aluminum what do you think
liquid death ladies and gentlemen yeah
it is it's giving me diamond water vibes
but diamond water they actually did sell
for like an insanely inflated yeah it
was five dollars
that [ __ ] well running it over diamond
energy ain't cheap
all right let's thank our sponsors and
then we're gonna get into the david
dubrick
uh ex jeff dubrick i actually have an
interesting uh update too i talked to
jeff on the phone last night i don't
think i told you guys that
you did
how'd that go i did are you good no i
don't know i'm saying you did you talked
to oh yeah i did we had a nice
conversation on the phone you guys meant
you guys are betting i'll tell you all
about it after we thank our sponsors
first we've got hairy razors
harry's razor
this month dump uh the madness of your
old expensive shaving return by trying
harry's betting on the underdog can pay
off big especially when a company like
harry's that teams up
with the best quality and construction
method in the razor game
and incredibly fair pricing i love
harry's i actually use it on my neck
either uses the same razor on her legs
and that [ __ ] lasts forever
yeah i uh i use them as well on my dome
and uh
that ain't easy it ain't easy yeah no
it's it's up for the challenge it's a
task and it's up for you yeah at that
surface area too uh yeah oh yeah
like if you picked up one of those cheap
plastic ones from the grocery store that
thing would
that thing
that's a one-time use and you probably
nick yourself in this process yeah it'll
mess you up yeah but you know what
harry's is the real deal new customers
can redeem a harry's trial set for just
three bucks when you go to harrys.com
h3 why should you try harry's well they
believe you shouldn't have to choose
between a close comfortable shave and a
fair price so they give you both in fact
harry's blades are designed to stay
sharp longer in a recent study guys who
shave four times a week said their
eighth shave was just as smooth as their
first that's a better experience with
every shave and saving over time here's
giving their best offer to our listeners
new harry's customers can redeem a
starter set you get a five blade razor
weighted handle foaming gel with aloe
and a travel cover to protect your
blades when you're on the go that's a 13
value for just three bucks there's never
truly a better time
to try harry's go to harry's dot com
slash h3 to try harry's today and thank
you very much
thank you thank you and thank you to
babel
if you want to learn a new language
and you want to have fun doing it
maybe you met a new cutie
in another country
or maybe you just want to uh
you know learn a little bit before you
go travel babble is here for you
whether you know whatever your goal is
it's got to be learning a new language
has got to be one of them this language
learning app has sold more than 10
million subs uh subscriptions
not only is learning a new language a
fun and engaging new hobby you can use
it while you check off traveling more
from your list the whole bible process
is addictively fun fast and easy babel
teaches bite-sized language lessons for
real real world use i've heard that
learning an additional language is
really good for the brain
actually
makes you think good and that's my
problem
i'm one language
that's both of our problems and nhl yeah
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
ai for the lesson plans but babel
lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching methods
have been scientifically proven to be
effective and with bible you could
choose from over 14 languages including
spanish french italian and german plus
battle speech recognition technology
helps you to improve your pronunciation
with act and accent there are so many
ways to learn with babylon addition
to lessons you can access podcast games
video stories and even live classes plus
it comes with a 20 day
money back guarantee start your new
language learning journey today with
babylon right now when you purchase a
three month babel subscription you'll
get an additional three months for free
that's right that's six months for the
price of three just go to babel.com and
use the promo code h3 that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code h3 babel it's language for life
and finally you know them you love them
it's stamps.com
if you use the post doll if you use mail
and you're not using stamps you are just
playing yourself because time is money
don't waste either with repeated trips
to the post office stamps.com you skip
the trip to focus on how to take your
small business the next level stamp.com
lets you print official postage right
from your computer it saves you money in
the process so you can spend less time
at the post office and more time making
your customer happy now
i've used stamps i know dan uh your
girlfriend uses stamps she does for her
uh for her art business she sells prints
and uh
has a patreon and stuff she sends out
rewards to people she's shipping stuff
literally five days a week and she's
just got the printer right next to her
computer
simple as possible you just uh it's got
a little scale
put it down on there prints the right
amount of postage either the mailman
picks it up or you can just switch by
the post it's like boom it seems
if you're using you know mailing stuff
it just seems like no-brainer this is
the way to do it
you print it you weigh it you leave it
at your door that's it you don't have to
think about it yeah thank you thank you
i love that steven just become our
unofficial uh
endorser he's on board with all thank
you steven sponsors you know they've
been for more than 20 years helping uh
businesses small and large alike
uh
get stuff done over a million businesses
they give you access
to the post office the ups services you
need right from your computer and you
get huge discounts you can't find
anywhere else 40 off usps rates and 76
off ups whether you're sending invoices
doing a side hustle or just a full-blown
warehouse shipping out orders stamp.com
is going to make your life easier
all you need is a computer with a
standard printer you don't need any
special supplies or equipment and you're
up and running in minutes printing
official postage for any letter any
package anywhere you'll want to send it
stop overpaying for shipping with
stamps.com sign up for the promo code h3
for a special offer that includes a four
week trial free postages and a digital
scale no long term commitments or
contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code h3
thank you
thank you
[Music]
all right so let's get into it eh
so yeah um before david uh put out his
podcast did you watch it do you guys
watch it yeah i watched both of them
yeah i did too they came out late jeff
posted this at like 3 a.m i was like
here we go
what was your what was your initial
reaction to david's
um
because the comment i immediately went
to the comments yeah and it was just
pure adoration and love and support for
david which i found bizarre because my
initial take and again you know i'm not
the biggest david doberg fan by now you
guys know that but i thought it was
disgusting i was repulsed by it
and i was like man i i can't be the only
one here right
i don't know
did you
well i i felt like he was being sincere
and that he
was going through some [ __ ] but the
question is is he going through [ __ ]
because
of what he put his friend through or
because of what he's going through now
you know like i feel like he's going
through [ __ ] but like there's actually
two real victims which right he's not
one of the real victims right and i'm
that that was the conflict in my mind
he's like i'm so sad i should be making
50 million dollars this year but instead
i'm only making 10.
uh
okay dude well
you almost killed your friend
and he has like a traumatic injury for
life
so i don't know but before all this
happened jeff call he texted me and he
said
hey can we talk
sure yeah let's talk
first thing he did
he apologized
for what happened with his body coming
to our house which i appreciated
he said i don't have to worry about it
it's not going to happen again which i
which i also appreciated i i i honestly
was worried i was worried like after we
did the last podcast with the all
with the italian you know with the
wiseguy character i come home and i say
listen i don't want no wise guys coming
to my house
i'm no wise guy i just play one on my
podcast
[Music]
you know
[Music]
so
[Music]
but anyway that's nice i appreciate it
because i i'm being like real paranoid
lately
you know
so jeff apologize his friend
isn't coming
uh he told me basically that
he thinks he he heard through the
grapevine that david was going to be
dropping this vid this uh
podcast
or i guess they invited him to be on
and he said no which i don't blame him i
mean it's kind of weird for him to sit
there jason called him and told him yeah
that is gonna be released
there's one point i think i'm just gonna
watch the whole thing but there was one
point where jason goes i think jeff's
gonna be really happy about this and i
was like what you just found that so odd
because they essentially blaming it
on jeff
the accident
um
and well this anyway yeah so
david put his out late at night
and then jeff uh put his out at like 3am
responding
i'm not sure how exactly to go about
this because
i wonder i wonder if i should just watch
david's and then we can kind of
paraphrase what jeff said because he
it's like watching the same thing twice
you know what i mean yeah there's a few
moments that i
highlighted out of jeff so if you want
to do that watch david's and then just a
couple of moments from jeff's response
to those big claims
maybe the easiest
yeah let's do it you know
something jeff kept telling me on the
phone was like you know
that he was
he has lied about things to protect
david
you know
always to protect david and
let's just watch the dang thing first of
all
terrible title
discussing what happened
what happened was he talking about the
essay or the excavator i missed the mark
with that one
now my hunch is you guys have probably
heard there's a big documentary coming
out by a huge creator that is meant to
be this is going to be very critical of
david someone that was previously very
close to him ah there was a [ __ ]
press release while i got tiptoe around
it jeff jeff said who it was casey
neistat
made a documentary about david they were
very close and very friendly
and what i how i understand it is he was
making a documentary about david you
know being the rising star of youtube
because i remember casey neistat was a
huge fan of david before he was even
popular like when we went to the creator
studio casey was there david was there
and i remember casey was like this guy
you got to follow him he's going to be
huge he's a genius
that's how i became a fan of david
because i watch casey so much in case
you always say his favorite creator was
david yeah he loved him
so casey's been kind of tailing uh
david for a couple years to shoot this
documentary of this rising star
and it turned in and he captured all
these controversies
with jeff and the insider article
and it turned into what was supposed to
be kind of like a nice puff piece
into a extremely critical
documentary of david
and i think david is scared about what's
going to come out in this documentary
and i think this whole thing is trying
to get ahead of it personally because
it's going to come out in like a week
right or it's being screened at cans in
a week i believe it's this weekend yeah
i think south by southwest
oh some film festival they're going to
be screening it and live streaming it so
people will be seeing it this weekend
and what what's in that documentary must
be really bad because it seems like he's
really nervous about it
and i think he's trying to get ahead of
all that
you know the guy hasn't said a word
about this for years he's been dragged
and just silently standing by all of a
sudden
comes out this saturday we said
so where does it come out because
is it south by southwest or is it
or is it canned so the people can know
all the sudden the guy wants to talk
about everything you know
when casey neistat has basically gone
against the family
you never go against the family casey
you understand
casey
i brought you and david be like i made
you casey neistat
you oh you that's what happens when
somebody who doesn't owe everything they
have
to david
ends up in the vlog squad you know what
i mean
[Music]
because all these other people are like
david
this and he he made who i am today
i'd be on the streets
oh let's read the synopsis under the
influence casey neistat when casey
neistat first sat down to interview
youtube sensation david dubrick
neither of them knew they were about to
capture one of the most
precipitous rise and falls in the
history of the internet in real time
david protected by the belief he's just
a kid with a camera has constantly
assumed risks
even as a story of essay breaks he's
busy busy covering up a near lethal
accident caught on film that's in the
synopsis casey says he's covering it up
in the real world these kinds of actions
have life-changing consequences but in
the gold rush uh ecosystem of social
media influence the audience decides
who's successful and who gets banished
forever
march 12th
6 45. uh yeah so that that's at south by
um and then it says right under on march
13th there is a online screening
worldwide so i think it looks like you
have to rsvp for it i'm sure it'll
premiere on some streaming services
later but you need an rsvp to watch a
video it's like an online because it's a
it's an
online component of this but if you guys
want to watch this then i guess you go
here and just
march 13 at 9am okay southwest yes
so that's pretty interesting you know
or if you happen to be in austin texas
you can go watch the screening in person
probably
uh casey you might have to go into
hiding after this one you know what i'm
saying
hey casey
oh you got new music
this is like the wise guy stuff i love
it's like a good fella the casino ace
rusty well done zack thank you hey casey
it'd be a shame if something happened to
you well that's like the jeff whitaker
it doesn't really work for david
and jeff's my best friend again
just kidding he's we're not best friends
but he apologized which i appreciate
listen casey
i'm gonna need you to bury this
documentary you're working on cause if
not
is she a shame if something happened to
you
you've got a beautiful family a nice
couple kids there
now
[Music]
accidents happen all the time
be a shame
let's just watch this
okay so here's david dubrick uh
discussing what happened dubrick dubrick
so that's a that's an important context
i think that's what i was thinking of
if you go to the comments people are
saying i cr jason it's all about how
jason's a great guy dave is a great guy
i do wonder if they're removing comments
because there's no [ __ ] way that
people are not
being critical of this
i just don't get it
well here let's watch it
it's 53 minutes the first 10 minutes
they don't really talk about it so i
wonder if i should skip forward it is
pretty entertaining though how they're
sucking each other off for the first 10
minutes because the first 10 minutes
she's just like
this is so it's just so amazing that
you're opening up finally and talking
about your feelings and i just think
it's so great
and then david's like i don't feel human
emotion
i thought i was empathetic but i don't
understand people and human emotion
basically and jason am i wrong and
jason's like it's so great that you're
opening up
he said he felt like he really is very
empathetic but maybe he's wrong maybe he
he doesn't notice uh what's wrong with
him so correct him if he's wrong
he's like i'm very empathetic but once
bad things happen to people i wonder why
do you care
i wouldn't care if that happened to me
let's watch
it what's up guys welcome back to views
sorry i
always on the low setting
nice sounds good good tone good register
thank you you're already in the pocket
bro my hand is shaking yeah it could be
the caffeine but this is weird
i had a little diarrhea just now
i'm just not on the white seats yeah
it's a bummer um yeah so one other thing
jeff told me it turned i think we all
suspected it but natalie really is a
little jizzlane maxwell
she really is a little well do you
prefer gi lane dan or do you like jizz
um well minus sex traffic
but in terms of like she just does
things for him
his dirty laundry yeah
yeah
maybe she does trafficking i don't i
don't have evidence to disprove that
nowhere to confirm it
i don't even know where where do we
start
how do we even do this this this podcast
has been building for some time yeah and
oh this this episode yeah this episode i
don't think it's this episode i think
it's okay i think it's what you no i'm
not saying it's not going to happen in
this episode yeah yeah yeah but i'm just
saying like i think
i mean you've been breaking yo is that a
v a v friend on his desk
that sick draft drawing
that honestly looks too good to be a vp
yeah you're right
too much detail bringing this up to me
for a while yeah like you were like we
make all these podcasts and we're always
talking about dicks and farts and
we never actually talk about like how
you're really feeling yeah yeah yeah
yeah and you always say like if it was
my podcast yes it is yeah you're like if
it was my podcast i talk about
everything yeah your [ __ ] podcast you
want to be here do everything to david
it was your [ __ ] as it wouldn't exist
sorry
are you chewing on
apple oh okay
it's done i swallowed it
i'm [ __ ] david dobrik don't you tell
me about your podcast you don't exist
without me don't you understand
shut your [ __ ] mouth you say only
nice things to me
this is as soon as the the camera's cut
you start slapping jason around yeah he
does i heard david slaps jason behind
the scenes
spits on him when he doesn't obey
whether good or bad i get away with that
on my vlogs too yeah i just feel like
guys i'm not feeling so good today and
then all the comments are like it's okay
jason we love you okay and and i
understand why you don't do that because
because when you started
when i met you
i you know i used to do like one-man
shows where i would like bear my soul to
like 25 people like that's literally
what i was doing before we should skip
this
yeah i think let's just get to the juice
because we're going to be pausing
everything this is going to be a 10 hour
yeah exactly so you're saying
10 minutes let's go 10 minutes thank you
yeah i'm just going to seem like a dick
because i'm just going to dissect every
stupid thing they say
it is going to be okay can i say
something really weird i noticed
watching this that trisha and jason
laugh the same exact way trish and i've
never seen anyone point this out but
trisha has this laugh where she goes
just like that and i think trisha no not
that one and she laughs exactly like
jesus i think she
stole jason's laugh
or like this it's gonna be okay
you know what i mean so like
yeah if i was to take it's not trust me
i'm on the other side
you got to pull that up someone's got to
pull that up
just saying just saying just saying i'm
telling you pull that up baby don't be
[ __ ]
oh there there you gotta choose the
family
uh
wait he just played the sound bite isn't
that the lap no no no no no you no no
there's two heads of this family
and the other head might get mad just
pull up the laugh who could who could
listen maybe we know who the real don is
don ela
listen ela's not here we need someone to
command the battlefield
the me may be a time when she comes back
maybe they won't
but until then
you follow my command
well something bad might happen to you
understand
now pull up that [ __ ] line
honestly i don't even know how i would
find that i mean
somebody will come with the receipts
check this card someone's got it already
someone discord send it to me okay no
but like that's how that is that's how i
look at it like you know
this stuff can't last properly
maybe you can
maybe i just
shot myself
in the face with that but
well well there's a lot of issues on the
table
and probably the first thing is is jeff
we should you know we should talk about
that and what's going on
and
how you feel about it right right
recently jeff our friend jeff whittick
posted some stuff about me
um
just about the accident about how things
have been handled and um
you didn't call him on a surgery yeah
yeah stuff like that
and i think and i think there's things
that i haven't really spoken about
um i've never spoken about the surgery
or the incident in general
um so i i think it's kind of time for
that
and we asked jeff to come today and be
on the podcast he didn't want to and we
respect that
right
because i i
yeah
i would prefer to do
to do that with him here
you know but that's also a reason i
don't like doing any of this stuff i
don't like doing it either i agree with
you i just i think like talking about
someone when they're not in the room
is like a really strange thing i think
you can tear open a person when they're
in the room right next to you and like
you're making eye contact but i think
it's a whole nother let's talk about
somebody when they're out there
is that it that's close yeah
do you see the resemblance
you pulled that up fast wait now hold on
i got to go back to jeff we were at 10
minutes hang on guys this is one of our
one of our discord mods uh i knew that
someone had that it's gonna be okay
you know what i mean okay wait so like
yeah if i was to take it's not trust me
i'm on the other side
[Laughter]
now play it
i'm just telling you it's a very
distinct blast and i think trish is
still laughing like jason
percent of the answers are like it's
gonna be okay
you know what i mean wait i gotta go i
gotta nail that uh if i was to take it's
not trust me i'm on the other side
[Laughter]
if i'm moses i'm saying girl you you
stop laughing i mean listen you gotta
drop the laugh
just saying
i feel like i'm the first person to
notice that yeah well i certainly didn't
connect it you're right
all right
yeah i gotta go back to that
it's just crazy good
yeah if i was to take it's not trust me
i'm on the other side
because you know that happens right like
when you spend time with someone you
like you absorb their characteristics we
all we all
felt that happened you could start to
laugh like them do mannerisms like them
i do find it very interesting she's
still got the laugh though
you know
just saying
all right let's keep
going how you feel about it right right
recently jeff our friend jeff whittick
posted some stuff about me
and and i think there's things that i
haven't really spoken about
um i've never spoken about the surgery
or the incident in general
um so i i think it's kind of time for
that
and we asked jeff to come today and be
on the podcast he didn't want to and we
respect that
zach can you pull the uh can you pull
the two laughs
um yeah can you do that zach
sure
pull the two laps and let's get those
going side by side okay
oh we have a comment someone from simply
1v i don't understand why it has to be
trisha copied him it's much more likely
he copied her you used her the whole
time for fame and attention okay i mean
maybe
yeah it's possible
we could track it i think someone needs
to see us eye this
find out who's stolen deep dive when did
they date in like 2017 or 18 like you
could easily see a sigh this yeah so
find it find a video
find a video of that laugh from trisha
pre
whenever it was guys no part in this
discard
get on that we need to see a side of
this [ __ ] all right guys let's get back
to the video that's what we're here to
watch
she took five percent of jason's life
now she took on 95 percent
[Laughter]
if you're looking for um jason's laugh
it's at around 10 minutes of this video
uh
zach
all right david get to the [ __ ] point
yeah
i would prefer to do to to do that with
him here yes we do you know but
that's also a reason i don't like doing
any of this stuff i don't like doing it
either i agree with you i just i think
like talking about someone when they're
not in the room
is like a really strange thing i think
you can tear open a person when they're
in the room right next to you and like
you're making eye contact but i think
it's a whole nother to talk about
somebody when they're not there with you
yeah um with that being said
um the jeff thing yeah the jeff thing is
is the [ __ ] worst because
before i even say anything um
like that is
that day
uh is like the worst the worst thing
that's ever happened to me and i wish i
could [ __ ] i would [ __ ] do and
imagine how jeff feels
the one thing that i feel is it's
constantly from his perspective
that he's the victim and forgetting that
there's actually two real victims
and it's very much like i am i am the
real victim here
that was a very how can you say it's the
worst thing that ever happened to you
toward it yes like imagine
i mean say like that was the worst day
of my life um sure i mean i think that's
valid like if you almost killed a very
good friend that that could be the worst
day of your life for sure but the worst
day that's ever happened to me is that
what i supported it it's just well it's
a reoccurring theme or maybe nitpicking
now but you guys will notice it and the
other thing is um wow i mean
i can't emphasize how close jeff was to
dying and david would be in jail he
would be exp he would probably be kicked
out of the country he would literally
lose everything he wouldn't be sitting
here with his friends and his microphone
and his fancy set and all this he would
be gone either in jail or back in
slovakia
and uh he should be kissing
jeff's feet every [ __ ] day
and thanking him thank you for not dying
thank you whatever you need please
thank you
anything to take that day back
um
my hand is shaking how about using two
hands to drive the excavator
um
like yeah i mean
anything like i'm being dead ass like i
wish it was me bro i can't handle that
he just said dead ass
while talking about the most traumatic
moment of his life
that took me out of it
yo that was so traumatic bro
[Music]
yo i'm being jeff dead
right now
bro that ass
can you imagine like a holocaust
survivor bro that was the worst
experience of my life dead ass
my whole family got like exterminated
dead ass the worst
inappropriate yep there i wish whatever
like it's like
it's the most unfortunate thing ever and
i think
and and
and it's a shitty it's an accident
that's what it was it's an accident like
i also want to make that clear i don't
know it's an accident of negligence
you understand of course you didn't mean
to do that
but it was an accident that was caused
by your gross negligence
as the organizer and the driver that's
why charges like manslaughter exist
it means you didn't mean to kill
somebody but it happened because
you were irresponsible you made an
accident it's not just an accident right
there is there is fault here
for you to own people think
that
there's there's never
a world where i would ever want that to
happen to a person it was never i was
never up there like driving the thing
wanting to hurt him or whatever it was
of course and nobody's accusing you of
that
so it's kind of disingenuous for you to
like
address that which nobody's nobody's
saying you intentionally did that thing
um
and i think recently so jeff's gone wait
jeff had a friend who said he did it on
purpose
who said that
our friend oh our
friend yeah friend of a friend you might
have done it on purpose well it's safe
to say he may not be the uh
he's the muscle for a reason you know
what i'm saying forget about it never
happened he's the muscle not the bra or
well i guess braun he's the not the
brains he's the brawn right
yeah
angry recently with me
and um and i don't know if this is
there's a lot of layers to it i feel
like and
and
you can correct me if i'm wrong but i
think one of the main reasons
um jeff is bummed with me right now is
um
because he saw me do
he saw me do an interview
where i said something
that i promised him i'd keep between us
and that's something he told you he's
talking about casey neistat's
documentary
he did an interview for casey
they'll get to it but i'll just tell you
now so it's not confusing he says that
the excavator thing was jeff's idea
and according to david jeff begged him
please don't tell anybody it was my idea
just confusing and weird but we'll get
into that i guess
um
yeah and i figured that that's what it
was and then you reaffirmed it when you
told me that
uh he's he's pissed that i broke a
promise
um
this is so hard to talk about because i
kind of want to [ __ ] sound yeah okay
so it was
it was the day of whatever it was it was
uh you've never talked about the
accident you want to go through it
yeah i mean we were filming a video like
my comeback video i haven't posted in a
while and we wanted to do something
exciting and there was this youtuber
that we were collaborating with for it
that like did these really cool like
um
like
really cool visuals of like people doing
the coolest things
and one of them
was um people were like
wakeboarding i don't know what that's
called
while holding on to an excavator
um and that was like one of like five
things we were gonna do that was like
the first activity that we had planned
to shoot
um and yeah the morning came where we
were in utah we were filming it
and uh
and yeah we were getting the shots wake
boarding
and um
and then
i remember jeff came up to one of my
buddies one of our friends i don't know
i say like that and then later to me and
he was like
he was like
this is [ __ ] boring as [ __ ] what are
we like preschoolers like let's do
something cool and
he said he wanted to swing from it and i
loved the idea i was like hell yeah
let's do it
um
so
i remember too like
right before we had gotten to utah jeff
todd and i were all getting skydive
certified so we were like
so do you
they're setting up this narrative that
it's jeff's idea
and this is all coordinated right so he
goes jeff was like well come on
sweep me around festa
or something like that what is this
[ __ ] [ __ ]
slam my face into this excavator make it
real interesting
and then natalie goes on
to establish more that it's jeff's fault
here
uh
jaslane maxwell here
traffic she doesn't traffic in
children she trafficks in human lives
apparently eyeballs
we had all done like 20 jumps out of an
airplane like we were like high on life
yeah right i remember when we all like
the three of us
had like this like
air of like not arrogance but just like
we had done something so amazing all
together and we had this like bonding
experience oh yeah and i remember like
when we landed at the airport
um
we just felt like so cool yeah and we
were so ready to like do we're like oh
we're gonna do all these like water
sports and stuff like we were just
jumping out of airplanes for a whole
week like yeah and um there was that
like
man this set is crazy isn't it it's like
so big and tall
there was that air of um
like excitement and like wanting to do
so many different things and like being
able to do you guys were adrenaline
junkies for like a week yeah exactly
right and so they're being like jeff was
all hyped up he was crazy he said spin
me around
faster where are we bus sees
i remember
you you you took one van in the morning
and then you know i took everybody else
in another van a couple hours later and
i remember going down dropping everybody
off and i had to poop
i remember i remember and i remember
i remember walking down and looking at
the stunt and being like i'm gonna check
this out i'm gonna see what everyone's
doing
and i saw it and it was just
that you know the crane just taking
people around wakeboarding and it was
pretty slow and i was like okay that
looks fine right i'm gonna go poop
and it was really far away from the rite
aid that i had to poop at it was it was
far from civilization like 15 minutes
and by the time i finished pooping
susie texted me and said you know you
guys were at utah valley hospital and oh
[ __ ] i didn't know you weren't there
yeah jason wasn't even it wasn't even
there and that that that eats me up um
that eats me up that i wasn't there yes
i i don't know what i would have done if
because i feel like you know me and matt
king are always the ones that are like
hang on
you know let's wait yeah
i mean yeah
so go ahead
yeah yeah so
well sorry yeah and i remember like
we had pulled up to that stunt the first
day and
um i remember walking up and todd was
wakeboarding for the first time this is
like when todd and i first started so
bait i mean am i right to say like
we were all just having a good time and
then jeff showed up and made it all
crazy
i mean that's kind of the vibe right
that they're that they're leading
towards
this jeff character he's out of control
he went skydiving and now
this is the day before this is the day
that that day yeah yeah it was early
that day it was 7 a.m
yeah and this is when todd and i had
first started like dating yeah and
there was always like these jokes
between todd jeff and i yes you know
about like todd and i dating and i
remember jeff was like oh
todd thinks he's so cool like
he's just like wakeboarding or whatever
and like because he was like we had just
done all these things we just jumped out
of a plane like a million billion times
now we're just like hanging on to like a
wakeboard um and there's like so many
more other cooler things that could be
done
and so i think that like there was just
this air of like everyone was trying to
like have fun and like do cool things it
was a comeback video there was a lot of
pressure on that i mean i i think
pressure on man or not oh
i think there's a lot i think there's a
lot to be said with just that as well
like i think that's why i don't want to
make
the kinds of videos i was making before
was is was there was this like pressure
to perform like ultimately what point
that jeff makes in his response is like
everything they're doing is for his
video they're not paid they don't have
benefits they're literally there
for him to make videos good so this
whole premise that like jeff was there
trying to make it more interesting and
pushing them to do crazy [ __ ]
uh
doesn't matter right it doesn't matter
at all because jeff david they're
ignoring the fact that david was driving
this excavator with one hand recording
in the other jeff makes a good point in
his video he's like they've been going
for six hours already like david
definitely knew how to handle for the
control and speed of the excavator and
he's like i wanted to do stuff i wasn't
looking to be parallel with the earth
and get his face slammed into the
excavator
so
it's like a lot of
they're missing the big point here which
is that
it doesn't none of that matters because
ultimately david is responsible
and i think even bringing anything any
of this up about jeff is super
inappropriate like
like this was all your idea if you're
gonna put people at the end of an
excavator you better have the safety
protocols to make sure that that that's
safe
and
and he didn't so i don't know this feels
like a weird collusion to try to
manipulate people to
to saying like it was partially jeff's
fault not david's fault
what do you got here on the right
this is a heavy topic so
i'm loath to uh to interrupt here
but i do have hey i love eating some
swedish meatballs in ikea if yeah you
got in okay so have you tasted the
meatballs
no not yet all right well give them a
taste and tell me what you think first
okay
i i bought some extra meatballs so we
have around 12
13 here so i i can afford having
one amazing uh transition
yeah this is a rough transition i'm not
gonna lie
there's a bit rough
not good yeah
but we we might get kicked out so
are those
really good actually yeah this no we're
not using the uh
we're back on the phone we're back at
free bridge yes we're back at
freebinding well they couldn't they they
were not able to sneak the camera back
in so all right guys
maybe bring the meatballs back
lunch all right just go chug up chug the
meatballs can you hear me now yes we're
getting here
put those balls in your [ __ ] mouth
god damn it just shovel man
one
who's got the timer three oh those are
little eh he's crushing it
he's struggling oh man he's not liking
the the swedish meatballs yeah
everything's alive
it's a lot of your mouth at once
all right you know what uh
oh he's making good progress here okay
this is really good content here to
interrupt
with
[Music]
okay slowing down he's like a chipmunk
with a bunch of balls in his mouth
he's
checking it was a wendy williams
transition
yeah it really was
all right you know what we'll check back
in with love uh i didn't realize we were
doing a free brittany situation yeah
we're just trying to respect our swedish
co-worker he's explained that no matter
what they're doing no matter how hard
the work week is
you don't take a br i mean you have to
take a break for fika nothing interrupts
speak at times that's true yeah we're
just very dedicated to the bit
all right you got you got those pulled
up is that also what's going on go ahead
dude that that's insane
somebody stole that laugh from the other
person
that's insane it's the same laugh you
guys
all right now now who's gonna take the
csi lead to figure out who did that
laugh earliest
uh i'm going to assign that to the
subreddit subreddit
i know
that you can come through on that it's
so musical it really is yeah that's
probably that's
a b sharp
b
[Laughter]
all right can you guys not
trying to talk about this damn
podcast okay thank you let's get back in
so where were we yeah they're
establishing that it's jeff's fault
or partially his fault right like he's
trying really wants people to think it
was an accident that it was jeff's fault
that uh yeah yo yay
i don't think what i just want to hear
is like i got carried away
i was
wanting to do anything for videos and i
put my friend's safety at risk
that's it
none of this oh jeff jeff said hey what
is this [ __ ] [ __ ] how is that relevant
hey jeff went skydiving he was crazy
yeah he wasn't controlling the excavator
bro what does that have to do with
anything
literally you endangered your friend
that's just say that
so there was like like
and not this is spin i don't know i'm
like 50 50 on it because it's like on
one side like
that's how things are made that are
great like everybody wants to contribute
everybody wants to make it bigger
everybody wants to make it better like
that's how great yeah usually people get
paid for their work
i find it so insane that david doesn't
pay any of the vlog swag guys no
benefits
it's it's and he he asks so much of them
too
it's really
incredible i gotta stop paying you guys
man you just gotta wanna make this show
great to make something great
definitely these make your own youtube
channels and get your own [ __ ] income
[Laughter]
this exposure is my payment
dude that's the best
yeah whenever we need the light in the
moment yeah play them together at the
same time
[Laughter]
wow it's even like the same like
tempo
someone says maybe i'm being biased um
biased on
but that i hate that i'm best friends
with jeff again
slash hate david
but i mean look david is the boss
yeah that's ultimately what's happening
he was the one controlling the excavator
with one hand
that's your fault david
yeah i mean ultimately
uh
even if he wasn't even in the excavator
even if he wasn't it's his channel it's
his content he didn't have he's the
executive producer that that's part of
the gig man but
you know what get all the money you get
all the responsibility too and you know
if you do
if you're going to be in that position
you need to be able to identify a
dangerous situation and
stop it before also he goes you know i
learned so much from that but it's not
the first time like jonah almost died
jumping over the pool on a motorcycle
yeah like you already got lucky once
with one of your friends getting
seriously injured
yeah and it's it's a little more than
just
something you can shrug off as a
learning experience like almost
murdering somebody
but it is way worse that he was driving
thank you lena right on top it is way
worse because
he's the one who spun it around super
fast
sorry i just have this glass here
but even you know even if it had been
natalie or one of the other people in
the vlog squad that was behind the
controls and he he was just laughing
from the sidelines it it's still it's
it's under the umbrella of his show you
know it it happened yeah legally i mean
it's his liability exactly but the fact
that he was driving with one hand and
spun it up right just makes it does make
it worse it makes it worse because he
can't this whole it was j if jeff was
like i want you
to spin me on an excavator
and
and whatever like no matter how much
jeff did anything it's [ __ ] your
fault bro
jeff of course contests all this in his
video anyway
great things are made it's like people
have a motive and people have a desire
to make something amazing i think that's
what helped with my videos is each and
every one of my friends wanted to
contribute and the reason they were so
good is because all my friends helped me
with the videos
and
and yeah so like on one side i think
like that's exactly how something great
is done but on the other side i could
see how like that environment can get
dangerous so when we got to the hospital
um
um
jeff was
what did he just say he said my friends
are eager to make the best video
possible but it can be dangerous
[Laughter]
again they don't have their motivation
is to make a video for you dude
that's it you're the only one making
money there it's in pretty good spirits
it's a really hard thing
to like navigate when you're in the
hospital with something like that
because you don't know whether or not to
be like like super serious and caring or
goofy right like i don't know how to do
that
um
and i remember i remember jeff told me
check my dms
and it was it was a video that he found
okay 15 minutes before the act now this
is this is wild this is this is wild
okay
go back here watch this part this this
is important for goofy right like i
don't know how to do that
um
and i remember i remember jeff told me
check my dms
and it was it was a video that he found
like 15 minutes before the accident that
somebody posted
and he said let's recreate this and it
was a guy
swinging from an excavator and flying
off i didn't see that dm until the
hospital and he jokes he's like i didn't
mean literally ha ha like he joked so he
says
jeff sent him he shows the dm right so
he's clearly trying to pass but he's
like hey i got the receipts
jeff sent me this video
which by the way he david didn't even
see
until the hospital
right so what the [ __ ] exactly is his
point he's trying to make here
like you were the one driving do you not
recall that
uh just trying to paint him as like a
thrill-seeking you know mania maniac
also i think it was to demonstrate that
if he wanted to put the blame on jeff he
could have done it with this and he
doesn't directly say it but i think
that's what he's trying to do i mean i
know i know he's trying to do that right
right but
he didn't even see it until jeff he was
already in the hospital
which i think he's like
trying to say like to clarify that i am
taking responsibility
then why show the dm like why he's
literally showing the private messages
of jeff
to make it look like it was his idea
which david never saw until after the
accident happened and you're the one
that controlled the speed
of the excavator
how the [ __ ] would jeff wanting to do
this have any impact on the accident
when you're the one controlling the
excavator
he's showing the dm i don't know this
[ __ ] just seems to be on the panel it's
disgusting it's weird this is a blatant
attempt to make it his fault
somebody posted
and he said let's recreate this and it
was a guy
swinging from an excavator and flying
off i didn't see that dm until the
hospital and he jokes he's like i didn't
mean literally ha ha like he joked um
that was the first time i saw that he
was joking he was fine
he nearly died and he was probably full
of so many narcotics he couldn't feel a
thing
but he told me it was all good
so no problem what's all this what i
don't know it's like again it's like
just say
i got carried away
i endangered my friend also yeah karina
did it before jeff there's in the video
documentary you can see corinna did it
first she gets super freaked out
and then
you can tell
i think in the documentary they show
that that david was like come on jeff
just do it for the shot
it seems like david
was was trying to persuade him to do it
after corinna was like [ __ ] this this is
too
freaky i honestly don't remember if they
showed up but i remember jeff saying
that he kept insisting but i don't
recall if it was actually made the cut
and i doubt it made the cut to be honest
but yeah he doesn't mention that karina
did it first and that she got too scared
and stopped so once again i don't give a
[ __ ]
if uh
you know was that daredevil guy who used
to jump over cliffs evil knievel i don't
care if evil knievel is riding in that
thing you're driving it
was the first time i opened it
um
and then he asked he's like can you can
you can you promise me one thing i said
what he's like can you just promise that
no one ever knows that this was my idea
and
i was like absolutely like he doesn't
really explain
i'm confused by this whole point
because i don't really get a good
explanation about this from david or
jeff according to david jeff said
promise me he's on his death jeff and
jeff was like this is so ridiculous that
like he almost died he's in the hospital
with his eye coming out of his head and
he goes promise me one thing never tell
anybody this was my idea
about a message that he didn't even see
until afterwards it doesn't make any
sense right
right it makes no sense i guess unless
he verbally
told him the idea as well
i don't even think david said that
detail
he didn't say it here but
yeah i guess he doesn't really clarify
whose idea it was i mean
it's not even like the person that had
the idea is the person in the wrong like
it's kind of it doesn't matter
the whole thing is
the idea itself isn't the problem the
idea the problem is that you did it
without any safety personnel training
proper you know protocols or anything
you just you just want it and somebody
got hurt i mean people do that like the
excavator thing wakeboarding like that's
a thing people go and do there's a way
to do it safely you just didn't do that
yeah
so it doesn't really matter whose idea
it was at not at all yeah so again the
whole point of bringing up whose idea
was is is like to deliberately off you
skate responsibility right yep which is
solely on david
i think in the end i was really confused
by what jeff was saying but in the end i
think
he was feeling insecure
about people
blaming him for what happened to him he
didn't want people to be like uh it was
jeff's idea he got what he deserved
he was afraid of that happening that's
kind of what he said
you're going to get hurt yeah thing
exactly
is an attitude that people have i mean i
guess is that what you took from it yeah
and he mentioned a similar situation
with jonah where jonah got hurt and they
kind of just made fun of him for it like
it became a meme after the fact are you
talking about the motorcycle
that's so [ __ ] up so i think yeah jeff
was like i don't want to be ridiculed
for almost dying so don't tell people
that this i don't think and in fact the
way that jeff said it was like i don't
even think jeff said was admitting hey
this is my idea i think he was just
saying don't tell anybody this was my
idea because i don't want to be
ridiculed for almost dying
i think that that that that makes sense
right
but the way david's saying it is like
please this was my idea i told you to
slam my face into this excavator promise
me not to tell anyone that i told you to
slam my face into excavator at 60 miles
per hour
there's no [ __ ] shot you know
that's not a big deal um and then
that's the promise i broke recently
um
and
i the fact that these guys think that
this is like interesting or
or compelling evidence to support him is
psychotic all of these people are
psychotic here for route this is just
not this is [ __ ] up it really is okay
and i had my problems with jeff
but the way they're doing this is really
disgusting
am i crazy or you guys agree because the
comments are universal the praise for
david well it's possible they're
filtering it but also
it's on his channel these are his fans
they're inclined to be on his side uh
maybe they're not maybe they're just he
has a lot of people that are buying his
uh version of the story
i mean it's tough when you see someone
you're watching them for four or five
years and you see nothing but positivity
and good times like
no matter what you see it's hard not to
want to believe them you know
so like the uh dan said majority his
fans
yeah i mean they they want
they don't want to believe that david's
a sociopath right you know they want to
believe he's a good guy this guy that
they've been fans of for years and so
you know they're gonna they're not gonna
pick it apart the way that we are
yeah and i mean people say he his way of
defending himself is like of course i
didn't do it on purpose it's like yeah
no [ __ ] yeah i don't think anybody
thinks he did
but i think it really just shows that
david doesn't take responsibility for
what happened to the girl and he doesn't
take responsibility for what happened to
jeff either he sees it himself
as the it's all it's all uh contr uh uh
factors outside his control that and
he's equally
uh victim as the other people as
the victim of circumstance like yeah i
set up a five sum and
it for dom who's a known predator how
could i know that something bad was
happening
right and i've done stunts where people
get
get seriously injured how could i know
that i could almost kill someone while
controlling an excavator without any
formal training with one hand yeah and
it's just at that level of success that
he has or had um and the amount of views
that he's making and
and really the amount of money that he's
making
there's just you're not some kids he
keeps portraying we're just we're just
friends shooting the [ __ ] and you know
running and gunning with the camera and
making stuff you're not like this is a
multi-million dollar business hire some
[ __ ] safety personnel dude if you
want to do dangerous stunts it's just
obvious totally
hey it's like
we go to like a water park and i [ __ ]
shoot off of the uh
i shoot off the slide and get splattered
on the concrete hey it was dan's idea
he wanted to go to work he wanted to
raise water
was your idea
i mean it's the it's the slide's fault
yeah
i mean there's ways to do it jackass has
existed for
for
decades at this point and yeah those
guys are moving i mean they get easier
[ __ ] than you've ever done and they do
it with medics on standby they go
through safety courses beforehand 100
ways to do it there's a huge disclaimer
done by professionals right supervised
by professionals we have a comment here
trisha 100 started laughing like jason
after she was with him
there you have it
straight
um yeah i didn't want to get too far off
topic again but um
heather petro what'd you what do you got
dan oh another one of our mods said that
it did a deep dive and they they came
with some receipts of some various
videos including a trisha laughing
compilation okay let's go
earliest instance of her uh laughing
like that is in a video
with shane from 2018 and they started
dating in summer of 2017. this is all
according to uh i knew it there's no way
i i don't feel that first of all
trisha's whole thing is like that she
takes different identities and like oh i
don't know who i am and i'm i'm not my
own person so i don't think there's any
chance that
that
jason took the laugh from trisha you
have to be honest
uh people are spamming you look cop
emojis in the chat say what so maybe
yeah he'd look back on the rails
it's such an interesting observation
and i'm not saying anything i'm not
saying anything
it's just the same laugh
absolutely get back on the rails thank
you ayla
yeah she's right okay
when she's got a point guys
she's got no arguing with the queen
but i felt like
nobody had ever pointed that out and i
just had this this epiphany last night
watching jason laugh
and i was like oh my god
i have to tell the world about this
right abey
isn't it you could have thought you can
admit it's interesting
um
i
uh he was my counselor i let you do my
talking it's not just maybe has some
serious ptsd from yeah why are you so
scared of you though
i don't think he's scared of you you're
not scared of her just you are
shaking in your boots what zach she can
be scary i'll say it's interesting
it's interesting it's interesting but
please see the oh [ __ ] the chat is
turning on me it's all ela cop now
all right and we're done we've we've
we've fully explored we've explored it
we've identified back to the podcast
nothing is on fire i repeat nothing is
on fire there you go let's just keep
moving like nothing happens that's right
and
and i don't know and and here's the
thing
i don't understand
why that bothered him so much because at
the end of the day
i was the one [ __ ] driving it it was
my video
i was the one sitting there it's [ __ ]
clear as day i am the one controlling
the thing
he got hurt because i was driving that's
it and i [ __ ] know that so why did he
spend the first 20 minutes talking about
how was jeff's idea like
he's mudding the water
and like i said i would
any chance i would get i would take that
back any chance i would get i believe
that so yeah let me ask you a question
if a magic genie came to david and said
you have two options
the accident never happened
or or you almost killed one of your best
friends
or they said either you'll go dead
you'll never had a career you're back
you're just a normal guy
or
and jeff's eye is healed
or you can live in the current timeline
do you really think he would choose jeff
is healed
hell no
hell [ __ ] no i don't know well enough
to say but
it does seem like a stretch
man they would not [ __ ] it would pick
current timeline every time
sitting in his million dollar studio
his 12 million dollar encino mansion
[ __ ] no bro he'd be like man [ __ ] that
guy's eye
you know he would that that'll be the
biggest of my life
my entire life it's easy to say i would
give anything when it's not an option
it's like fairy comes
i should get real i really hope there's
not a moment that that i regret as much
as that one uh
yeah i thought this was interesting he
goes
and you think that that'll be the
biggest regret of my life we'll see
you still you're pretty young
and you [ __ ] up a lot
something tells me it won't
my entire life i really hope there's not
a moment that that i regret as much as
that one
um
um
but yeah
and then and then we
yeah it's like a pride thing he he
didn't want okay yeah whatever it was i
just okay whatever it was i was like yes
i can i can keep that
and then
and then it got like a little bit
but was it even jeff's idea like i don't
think they showed that it was his idea
the excavator thing was david's idea he
went to collab with the guy
i don't understand this whole thing who
gives a [ __ ]
we started filming uh we okay so there's
some things that i wish jeff was a
little bit more truthful on but given
the circumstance it's so hard because
he's because he's hurt so that's why i
hate talking about this because he is a
victim like he got [ __ ] hurt his face
is crushing let's go to multiple
surgeries like i understand that so it's
like really tough like going back and
forth here when this is so like here's
some yeah like i was like this is my
biggest cigarette the essay not as much
now i don't regret that as much
here are some of the things that he's
told me that
that i you know
are legitimate they're legitimate gripes
you know like
um
he came to the house to do a hawaii
video
and he thought
and you you had planned the hawaii trip
the same day as one of his surgeries
so there was no way that he could go to
hawaii but he was here for the return of
the video
so
which is
yeah we didn't we didn't plan that trip
until we didn't know when he was getting
his surgeries we never know and so jeff
says natalie was
the one who was scheduling his surgeries
and knew exactly when they were
yeah he his like exact quote was
something along the lines of it's not
like scheduling a haircut like you have
to schedule it months ahead of time
which is right
especially yeah totally
so and then the other really interesting
thing that jeff says and i recommend you
guys go watch his response it is
interesting it's just too redundant to
watch both
uh he says that
that basically jeff or david like
tricked him into being in this vlog
where
he wanted everyone to come to his house
to talk about the accident and everyone
went there to have like a serious
conversation and then david was like um
anyway guys i'm back and he whips out
the camera just starts filming everyone
and they thought they were gonna be
having a serious conversation and he's
like guys we're going to hawaii
and jeff was there
no
and then jeff was like well i felt
awkward because he's going to use the
footage anyway so i didn't want to be
like
you know
yeah because it made him look like they
were all good
and jeff's like we weren't all good he
invited me over to have a serious
conversation and then he whipped out the
camera told everyone they're going to
hawaii on the day that jeff's surgery
was so he couldn't even go so he was in
the intro of the video and then he
wasn't in the actual video
and he didn't even cut him or anything
if that's really how it went down that
is that actually that's the next level
like conducivity
it is how it went down because jeff they
they all confirmed that it was on the
same day of surgery and he wasn't there
in hawaii
he said that david mentioned that moving
forward they'll be hr and everyone will
review videos and whatnot
um he says which never happened by the
way oh man
yeah that's really next
he's like hey guys i want to have a
serious conversation
whips out the camera we're all going to
hawaii except you jeff
wow pretty good right yeah that's
yeah
we didn't we didn't plan that drink
right away like everyone came i
surprised him with the trip right like
on camera i said it's in three days like
just to get a cool reaction i don't even
know if i included that but
um but it wasn't for like weeks after
right because we were checking
everyone's schedule and then his surgery
came up last minute so that wasn't
yes i think david's lying because these
surgeries don't come up last minute he's
right you schedule these months in
advance and as the guy who's paying his
[ __ ] bill he should know when his
surgery is
he's a liar he's lying
listen jeff you can't come on the trip
your eyes it doesn't look good on camera
i don't like to remind people what a
[ __ ] liar dude
why don't you just stay home and take it
easy
we'll have a good time in hawaii without
you we'll send you a postcard
oh
i haven't seen this
new composition here hey
listen jeff well done we'll send you a
nice postcard
people they don't like to see the eye
it makes them
i'm gonna uncomfortable
one of these
maybe get a shave in the
the mullet not working for me
you know we'll be swimming you can't
even get the eye wet what's the point
[Music]
do i wish it didn't happen surely
sure i do
what is that pronunciation
but i can't change what's what
so go home
i'll make sure you're good with the
painkillers and all that i got a guy
just peeled okay
well a fun time you take care
when people see the eye it makes them a
little uncomfortable
the and our vlogs are all about having a
good time you see a guy with a busted
eye
not that fun
no no i'm just saying
[Music]
you just rest up
[Music]
all right take care jeffy boy
and stay out of trouble all right
[Music]
good luck with the surgery
i hope it goes real good for you
okay ethan
and the the hospital bills
which is which is one of his gripes
and his credit is messed up is what he
told me but you guys are saying that you
have tried to pay the hospital bills
right but you're he his assistant hasn't
reached back out well let me get into
that okay i i think
it's a huge dispute
jeff says he works with like a big time
top notch his assistant is on them all
the time
they say
they never heard from his assistant
so there's a huge discrepancy here
about
what's going on and what's real
interesting is
again and then they once again conflate
they go i've been paying his bills this
whole time and jeff never says he wasn't
paying his bills he just said that he
was late and it [ __ ] up his credit
right
so he couldn't buy a house and
jeff says something really interesting
about natalie too like they were kept
writing natalie emails and then natalie
goes so what are you gonna do sue us no
she said some really [ __ ] obnoxious
remark about that like he's missing the
bills oh and then another thing jeff
said is that he was trying to get some
experimental like stem cell treatment to
fix his [ __ ] brain because he has
brain damage and and david goes i'll go
i'll go halves with you
i won't pay for it all
i'll go halves
that's [ __ ] insane i mean why nickel
and diamond at that point like that in
someone's brain
you're committed it's the worst moment
of my life
that being said i'll go halves
i gave you a little brain damage
and david doesn't dispute that either by
the way
you know
jeff also said he was waiting for like
a sponsorship to come through before he
paid him for it
and another thing jeff said that was
good is david has not jeff is not the
first person david's blinded he blinded
his childhood friend i remember we
talked about and then he only paid for
the medical research in a sponsored
video
yeah apparently it was like fifty
thousand dollars sponsors paid david
like a hundred and fifty thousand so
jeff so david had to wait to make a
hundred thousand dollars
to pay for his friend who we blinded
50 000
listen it doesn't make sense unless i'm
getting you know
i got to get a little taste myself
but can you believe the balls on this
[ __ ] to go he's like listen there's this
there's this cutting edge surgery stem
cells
it's incredible they take the stand the
cells they stem they spread the heal
it's incredible technology
they say you can fix my brain damage
from you know uh when you slammed me
into a [ __ ] excavator
and david's like i'll go halves
what
no this can't be true
what do you mean chat said it was a
triller sponsorship oh yeah yeah it was
no
trailer sponsored his friend getting eye
surgery yep
oh my god
yeah i'm seeing some people in the chat
saying that medical bills don't go
against your credit that's the truth in
most instances but not always
just to clarify
i used to work in the field i know
i mean the medical field so [ __ ] they
could be like it's it's hey your eyes
falling out it's elective
well you don't need it if you don't pay
it it goes the collection yeah what
happened yeah i mean i've had medical
bills back when i was poor go to
collection
in most instances it doesn't but it's
more for smaller like smaller amounts
they don't count it against you yeah i
know it's weird okay
you think the opposite yeah you like
that trailer by the way triller got tr
that sponsorship did real good for them
david hasn't posted on trailer in like a
year
brian kavanagh is a force of nature
i regret this more than anything in my
life and i would do anything to take it
back except pay for experimental stem
cells research to come to repair his
brain
damage he's gonna have to pay for that
himself
yeah i caused him brain damage
he's gonna have to pay for that himself
i think the hospital bills this is tough
i'm not like trying to speak for jeff
but i think it's fair that no someone
because he's not here um
but that stuff that stuff is tough
because i think it goes along with
what i'm about to say so
well let me get to the house should i
talk about the hospital bills or should
i go
i think we skipped a lot here yep okay
so can i go back okay so let me let me
go back so
that then we started filming
there's a lot of things that i wish
were more like honest and transparent
um and and that was that
it was
jeff wanted to keep the accident
to ourselves for a while um i think he
wasn't he also just wasn't comfortable
with like the way that he looked he
didn't want to show people until
you know he was ready that's
understandable right and and i and what
bums me out is
i see a lot of things i don't know if he
said it or where it was like
put into the universe that like i kept
this from people
like i mean for multiple reasons i
wouldn't keep that from people that's
interesting because casey neistat who's
a very fair
non-dramatic person literally says in
the synopsis of his documentary that
he's covering up the accident
said that said he's covered in the
synopsis i mean i'd have to see it to
to see if that just saying an accurate
description or not but
well jeff said look dude i didn't want
to talk about it immediately but that
was two years ago and this is the first
time you're talking about it
so
but one it's because it's his [ __ ]
face it's his life like he's allowed to
share it whenever
and two that would just be extreme by
the way i just can't go over the fact
that he wouldn't pay for the stem cell
brain like if he really cared if he
really felt bad if he's really happy
that he's not in jail for manslaughter
he would have paid that without blinking
but he's like i'll go half with you i
mean what the [ __ ] are you saying dude
you stat is just proof
that he doesn't give a [ __ ] really
stupid of me trying to hide something as
brutal as that like i would never ever
do that and that never happened that was
that was we were following his lead so
when he wanted to make a doc
like i was there like i was like
whatever you need me to do like
however i'm going to be in this like i
i'll be in it
um
and i think the doc is where
where things started to to get a little
a little strange because i remember we
were in utah we went to like three or
four surgeries with him i'm not sure
back to utah
hey uh
who wants some taco bell or some [ __ ]
what's happening back there
um trump is on the milk podcast
trump's on milk what
dude those [ __ ] guys are the best man
you gotta love it what a meeting of mine
hey trump you want some happy dad
seltzer
69.
is he is it live or they just announced
it it premiered two hours ago it's live
holy [ __ ]
they call them dumps
dude what are they gonna talk about they
can talk about election fraud with the
nulc boys
read the title because the title is epic
donald trump on world war three talking
to putin and joe rogan fulsome podcast
how the [ __ ] thing is
and talking to joe rogan
that's crazy
i'm sorry buddy well some dumps there's
there's friday's episode right there
that's true man
i thought
actually two good podcasts to review on
friday i'm excited about it [ __ ]
your mom's basement where keemstar said
that you stole the idea for friend of
mine oh what was his evidence for that
uh ian took lead on that you should
let's let's save it save it it's [ __ ]
gold it says
this morning
is it serious
oh it's serious really oh yeah
okay
there's some high level uh
some eye level discussion about the
ukraine crisis on uh on this podcast as
well between face blanks and keem wow i
wonder who has the better analysis trump
and the nilk boys or uh keemstar and uh
faze banks god i so much look forward to
on friday
i could hardly get through this i'm so
excited
i'm just spitting fast oh yeah did you
anyone watch mr beast on rogan was that
any good uh cameron i said he did oh
right i listened to it this morning
there you go you listen to the whole
thing what'd you think
uh it's kind of like
like if you have like a science
experiment and and you're trying to
explain it to your dad
it's always like mr beast's like so so
we like
i walked like a marathon in big shoes
and joe's like whoa
that's pretty cool
just over that's what i was afraid it
would be and that's the whole vibe
because he said he he knows of mr
beester's daughter his daughter's a big
fan so it seems kind of like
so you're like a cool guy right that's
what i that's what i meant when i was
like so how do you make money on youtube
right you can make money on youtube
that's crazy i mean i know joe rogan
made a lot of money on youtube so
i had a perfect idea
all right let's get through this you
guys want to order food though i'm
starving over here
i got food requirements um
i'm down italian hey does anyone want
some mcdonald's
i want a canal oh i love this backdrop
yeah this is this is great
listen
how about sending my message
with some pepperoni and cheese
get the vlog
leave the eye
bring bring the camera leave the eye
[Laughter]
don't kill me for that joke i've been
holding that one in for a while
that's funny i love pizza and i love
people no
that's very good
[Laughter]
what do you guys want to eat
[Music]
taco bell
oh
just keep it real i'm [ __ ] always
down for taco bell for some tv taco bell
yesterday bro i taco bell is not turned
into my favorite fast food it hits so
[ __ ] hard oh my i'm gonna have to
pull the receipts on you dude i have
been espousing i never said i never said
a bad word about taco bell other than
that they gave us ten dollars you're
gonna regret saying that
say what you're gonna regret saying that
just now because there is video evidence
we years ago did fast food tearless and
i was trying to argue for taco bell
being s here and you were like no
[ __ ] way that's like sea tear
yeah dude i was in a different place
and that's okay and i i am glad that
you've seen the light i'm not trying to
come down on you here but you know i'm
not i'm not willing to say they're asked
here maybe they're a tier
it's a voo it's a mood it's a
vibe the chat is saying
i can't eat kevin
i'm gonna send my who sam sam can you
order
she's not up here she's nina can you
already already speeding down the road
to taco bell she heard you heard that
and she jumped in her car i'll i'll tell
text you my order
yes so
um
i want 20 tacos
we surprisingly seem to have a lot of
sopranos fans in the chat they're making
a lot of sopranos references
it's a great show why it's like the most
one of the most popular ones i feel like
a lot of people like around my age
aren't familiar we're i'm surprised
that's true i watched it zach loves like
mob movies and stuff like that if zack
finally watches it it will become his
favorite show of all time i'm pretty
sure here i'll give you guys and
actually we'll regret it because he will
endlessly quote it yeah
i'll give you guys my polly walnuts
impersonation you ready what's that
drink to the the baja blah blah blah
baby let's get blasted here and switch
to me blast dude
[Music]
that was my impersonation
okay
that's it okay
you see it
[Applause]
seriously didn't i'm kidding
all right let's make our way through
this guys
get your orders to pro and tell love and
camp too because they might want to okay
get your orders in to lena
all right back on track
and one of them we were filming the doc
and one of his guys that works with him
went up to taylor and was like we
we really want to make david cry in this
piece we really want him to know what
he's done and there was more
of what he said to taylor but that was
kind of the thing that resonated with me
the most and that's where i started to
feel like oh [ __ ] like what's going on
here like
someone's not being transparent with me
here okay this is real interesting
so when jeff is filming his documentary
about the accident
and david was in it he's saying they
wanted him to cry and that scared him he
felt like he was being manipulated even
if it's true what the [ __ ] is wrong with
showing remorse because david doesn't
want to accept responsibility he said i
felt like i was being pushed into a
corner what could he possibly being
pushed into a corner being looked like
he's responsible what else what other
explanation is there for that
they fed they were trying to make me
show remorse and i felt uneasy about
that
i
genuinely what could he mean by that
to taylor well that was kind of the
thing that wasn't i mean he probably did
feel remorse but maybe just
doing it on cue i could see i could
maybe see david's the guy who [ __ ]
lives his whole career telling people
what to do well maybe
he got a taste of his own medicine and
realized that well anyway that
doesn't really work
jeff said
that they were basically like
did the whole documentary and he didn't
show any remorse he didn't show any
sorry jeff was trying to make him look
good as possible in the documentary for
a redemption arc and he's like we were
telling him to show some remorse so that
he didn't come out looking like a
psychopath
and so david turned it into
they they were trying to make me show
remorse it made me very uncomfortable
yeah
i yeah
you're probably you're but yeah
i'm a person that like i don't cry very
often even when i'm i'm pretty emotional
uh and like if i were asked to
do that on camera uh i would i would
feel awkward about it as well so i can
kind of sympathize with what he's saying
there
but what you're saying about jeff trying
to do him a favor
jeff said it was three hours of footage
and he showed no emotion
so he was like uh jeff and i believe
jeff because this whole time he's been
trying to
cover for david yeah he was like i
wanted to do a redemption arc for you i
wanted everyone to come out winning
so i just find it really [ __ ]
pathetic that he's trying to act like
they were trying to get him if you were
crying and showing remorse it would look
good for you they weren't trying to do
anything that would make you look bad
so again
putting it on jeff david does seem to
he doesn't seem to struggle with the
normal human interaction and i don't
know if it's something inherent with him
or if it's just the matter of him being
super famous from how old was he when he
like hit it big on youtube like 19 20
years old well he started even before
then on vine
oh just like as a teenager or whatever
and i think of the series pretty young
he was something i don't think so i mean
i think he probably either has like
maybe some asperger's or some
sociopathy that that doesn't allow him
to
feel empathy yeah maybe maybe probably
the empathy thing because he doesn't
seem
autistic although sometimes it's very
minor you know what i mean
i think he i think he honestly is a
sociopath and doesn't understand empathy
yeah i mean they say one in 100 right or
something higher than that it is a lot
it's
whatever i forget what the stat is but
it's like higher than you'd think so
yeah i'm an empath so i wouldn't know
[Music]
red flag
red flag alert i just feel things so
strongly i wouldn't know anything your
bio if your bio says empath uh
i'm an
or philanthropist in your instagram bio
i'm a cr also i'm into crypto yes and
hashtag i have an nft for a uh icon and
i have i'm an empath
that's where i started to feel like oh
[ __ ] like what's going on here like
they wanted me to show emotion what's
going on here so some kind of hit job
one's not being transparent with me here
like i almost feel like i'm being pushed
into a corner
that made me feel really uncomfortable
he says pushed into a corner
they says we want you to show remorse
you're pushing me into a corner what
does he mean no one puts david
accepting responsibility
that's it
yeah somebody said i think this is
probably true david's lawyers are
telling him not to admit fault for a
potential lawsuit i've made that point
in the past when we were talking about
this i i
i think that there may be a lot of truth
to that but in that case it's like why
even make this podcast was the public
pressure just so much that he had to
make a statement i think his attorney i
think the real reason he never talked
about it because his attorneys were like
don't [ __ ] talk about this right yeah
no i i think that's a he's lying he's
lying that's a fair point his reasons
his rationale it's all just
he's he's he's lying
it's all self-preservation with david
100
and um
but yeah i mean at this point he's
[ __ ] like
if jeff wants to sue him i feel like
it's an easy dub
and from what i understand uh based on
and jeff told me he's gonna sue him so
that's good at the very end of his video
he says it he says well let the courts
decide he goes i'm not gonna beat your
ass i don't do that no more
you just changed me i'm an adult
i actually said that i don't do that
because i don't beat up people no more
i'm gonna sue you he called off the hit
isn't that an old shoe nice sound drop
that we used to play all the time jimmy
lee
oh it's jimmy i don't croon no more yeah
i don't crew no more i'm a dentist let's
see i put actually put him in touch with
some some good attorneys jeff
so
get the ball rolling for him i think he
should
get a nice chunk of change i'll go to
hawaii
send you a postcard from hawaii david
[Music]
they put an eye in it hey david here's a
fedex it's a postcard from hawaii with a
fish eye with a rad eye
it's a sicilian message
all right come on we're only halfway
through for christ's sake jared and um
hey why what's wrong with what what is
wrong with you crying in the dark even
natalie who's like the old like i say g
lane maxwell up in this [ __ ] lady
macbeth even her she's like what's wrong
with crying well so
what does it say well because it's just
like a weird thing to say it's just
weird i felt like it was like wow
correct me if i'm wrong but
he she's asking because
he said that someone told him to cry
and he felt like it was
i know you already went through it but
just to clarify
what's being said
like she's asking what's wrong about
crying he's saying that someone told me
to cry no he already said that right
yeah i know but
and he said it's just a weird thing to
say that to me felt like
i don't know he can't explain it he
can't explain it it's just it's it's
psychotic like
it just didn't feel it just felt
it just felt weird yeah
and and also i think you
you know but why even bring it up like
he obviously can't unpack it in an
articulate way
he asked me to cry you see he's a phony
the doc came after a bunch of other bad
[ __ ] that happened
right and i think it was came at the
wrong time and then a lot of other bad
[ __ ] which we won't talk about
and
and it's tough with like
and it's tough and and and then the doc
got into things like his doc got into
things like
how like i'm not there for him like we
don't talk enough and and
a lot of that was true like
i've never had a harder time
communicating with a person than i have
with him during this
um
and
he wasn't useful to me anymore nobody
wants to see a guy with a busted eye
it's just not fun
and you know it's for multiple reasons
it's for
me [ __ ] just
being bad at that [ __ ] not knowing how
to handle like such a serious situation
and i also didn't know if you needed
space like every time i would talk to
him
jeff is like a guy who like
is very tough when you're to his face
and he's like i don't need this
i don't need you doing this like i'm
good i'm strong but then when you create
that distance
it's like
what the [ __ ] yep he's not [ __ ] not
not talking to me and then like
when my other friends would go talk to
him he'd tell me he's like if i ever see
dave i'm gonna [ __ ] beat his ass
right so it's like
and that happened multiple times from
multiple different friends where he
would like complain about so like i
wouldn't know like actually do you want
to see me more
that i believe yeah he said the same
thing to me exactly
so you can beat my like i don't know i
don't know
i don't know how to go about that i
don't know
i think
i know i know you think that he's a
sociopath and maybe because there are a
lot of signs there but i think it's also
possible like i said it's just like this
guy that grew up on social media he's
been in the spotlight since he was 16. i
think emotionally he's extremely
immature because he doesn't have
real relationships in his life and maybe
that is a byproduct of being you know
sociopathic or something like that but
when you when your entire existence is
this this view chasing and and uh clout
chasing and everything is everything's
being recorded everything's being done
and all of your interactions are are
fake and stilted like this and then
something like this really real happens
and it happens to somebody that you're
friends with who's somebody like jeff
who
i
like david just said he's kind of he's
unhinged at times like yeah and he's
right he's gonna kick his ass if he
talks to him and stuff
i think he just
he i kind of believe him when he just
says i had no [ __ ] idea how to handle
this situation i think there is some
truth but i also think he's he's
conflating a a two-year period jeff
wasn't openly hostile to him until
somewhat recently
the past six months right so i do think
it's totally valid that you know the
truth of somewhere in the middle where
it's like
there's probably months would go by
where jeff was just you know sitting at
home [ __ ] suffering right and david
didn't come reach out right and he's
getting and
then yeah and david probably has in the
back of his head like oh maybe i should
see
if jeff's okay but just i'll do it later
and puts it off for months until all of
a sudden he's got jeff in his dms
threatening to beat his ass you know
what i mean and like
i don't know it's just we've seen enough
of jeff to know that he can be very
volatile we we we understand that
firsthand now and so for sure yeah um
and
i everything i said before still stands
i do think that david is is
being slippery trying to
escape responsibility for all this and
shift blame and everything but i i can
kind of understand why a dude like him
handled this so badly because i just
don't think i think that he's
got the emotional development of a
teenager still in his mid-20s because of
just the life that he's led for himself
it's like illicit vlogitis vlog-itis
exactly i mean we've seen it on vlog
items
like this disease that people that that
entire existence is on social media and
i think
you know i think you
managed to escape it ethan because you
you
you started your career on youtube as an
old guy for youtube i mean you're right
are you an empath
hell no you sure
hell no
i used to be you might be an empath
now i drop that [ __ ] baby
well regardless of of if he's a
sociopath or emotionally stunted or
whatever
yeah like like okay there is jeff can't
be easy to maintain a friendship for
that with especially when he's it's
complicated especially when he's yeah
[ __ ]
brain damage
i don't know how to gently say that but
you know yeah he might you know it might
it might if he already was inclined to
be like this impulsive dude i mean it
you know you see it all the time with uh
what's the condition football players
get that uh
make see i think it's c-e-t
or whatever yeah i mean that [ __ ] yeah
yeah you're right i mean on this one
it's it's hard to it's hard to know
for sure i'm with you
in a way that where it's not hurting him
more seeing me because like because like
that that accident is so bad where like
i would understand if he wouldn't want
to see me because i'm associated with
like yeah such a [ __ ] [ __ ] time
by the way this is a good moment of one
of my favorite moments he described
almost killing him as a [ __ ] [ __ ]
time
just stood out to me more seeing me
because like because like that that
was such a [ __ ] time i would understand
if he wouldn't want to see me because
i'm associated with like yeah such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] time it's just a [ __ ]
[ __ ] time man
just putting it lightly yeah it was
definitely a doozy for sure it was a
dude honestly it was a doozy and i would
understand
that was a big old oopsie
just a [ __ ] [ __ ] time
hey when i cracked your skull open like
a pumpkin
you remember you were dangling head up
leaking from your brain like a like a
twisted up marionette that was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] time
and
and back to
and back to the the secret that he
wanted me to keep
um
i
i was all should we call
people are wondering if we should change
dan the hater to dan the empath
please don't do that funny not a [ __ ]
answer it's not as catchy
it's kind of funny though
force him to be all emp
i don't want that title yeah that title
is cursed at this point what he's a mix
yeah you're an impedicator because
you're not you're not an empath for jeff
you hate jeff
you hate jeff i don't know if i hate him
but he does
this whole song this whole saga with him
has not endeared him to me no no no no
no no
danny i honestly i i i just really feel
bad for him ultimately despite
everything because
his injury is [ __ ] horrible and he
very well may have brain damage it's
making him act in a way that's more
unhinged and like just dealing with this
[ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
i just feel horrible for it it's just a
tough situation for that but i i feel
like
i can take
you know
80 percent of the responsibility 90 100
of the response i can take 80 percent of
the responsibility
what other who where else does that go
to he go i love how he goes 80 90 100.
where else does the responsibility go to
so he is literally blaming jeff he says
jeff could take
twenty percent
for what
why is jeff taking twenty percent
in this in uh yeah
what what is the what did he do that
makes it his fault just the fact that he
agreed to do it he showed me a video
that i only saw after the accident it
said twenty percent his fault i mean
that part
yeah i don't know i don't know what you
could possibly i put on him really i was
all hands on deck for that but i i feel
like yeah he started at 80 because he
does he's literally saying i don't take
100 percent
i mean i think he wanted to start even
lower i think what he wanted to say is
i'll take 50 percent that's why he says
hey i'll go 50 on fixing that brain of
yours
i don't know he really doesn't think
it's his fault entirely
i can take
you know
80 percent of the responsibility percent
100 of the responsibility for the actual
why started 80. whatever he needs me to
do
but
that you know then when it gets to the
point where it started to feel like i
was taking 150 of the responsibility
that doesn't make sense bro you can only
take a hundred percent
i think by a hundred and fifty percent
he means a hundred percent
and he really feels like he's fifty
percent
i draw the line at a hundred fifty
percent
now theoretically that's impossible
there's only a hundred percent
responsibility to go around i was taking
too much responsibility
i started to see things like
like david [ __ ] force his friend up
there like all this kind of stuff like
that was just [ __ ] insane and it like
felt like
people thought i like lily sent him up
there
just so he can [ __ ] swing off this
thing right like that was not the case
and like the more and more that happened
the more i was that's just gossip i mean
you're just bitching about nothing
important
you know eighty percent of
responsibility and fifty percent of the
cost be said very good point
you're just you're talking about gossip
like the [ __ ] doesn't matter bro you're
talking you you're not taking a hundred
percent i was like what is going on like
this is not what happened it was
it was
because you guys covered
like why is it what is going on why are
people coming up all these crazy
theories right that's true you covered
it up yeah and trisha had like the intel
and [ __ ] and apparently someone posted
oh one of the girls at the there was
like a bystander there who filmed it put
online and they covered it up so
successfully that people like started to
think it was a myth and it never
happened remember people who were saying
that trisha was making the whole thing
up which is crazy to think about now
yeah
on that one yeah no there were straight
up people saying that the whole thing
was [ __ ] she was making it up out of
spite yeah just because she is crazy
yeah
um wow
yeah
yeah this is stupid like he's being like
people were lying about me
it's like well of course dumbass who
gives a [ __ ] about gossip
you almost killed him she's the [ __ ] up
you're not the victim [ __ ]
you did that
we made and it was a complete accident
and i'm so [ __ ] sorry again he keeps
emphasizing it was a total accident
again accident of negligence bro it
happened but it did and there's there's
no going back from that like there's
nothing we can do
um
and and yeah i wish it was more like
that and then when it started to be like
more 150
on me it
i
i started to get i don't know i guess
like it just freaked me out more i was
just like i don't know i don't know
what's going on i don't know
um and then in terms of and then people
really started blaming me and that
scared the [ __ ] out of me
150 percent
what are you saying
idiot if it's like medical payments um
so far
we've paid um i think i i just had
accounting check and it was like seventy
eight thousand dollars of surgery and i
don't know
what that's lower than i would have
expected that's nothing especially for
david who is fabulously rich
that's way lower really 78 grand nothing
he's had like eight surgeries yeah
what jeff said in his that it's like 10k
a pop maybe it's a copay because he
probably has an umbrella policy there's
gotta be yeah there's got to be more to
those charges because that seems that
seems extremely i think it's just like
a deductible surgery on your head yeah
so um
why bring up the amount again like i
guess it sounds like a lot of money to
most people but i know
yeah i spend that like a month
the american medical system having eight
surgeries on your [ __ ] skull that is
that is 78 000 i spend that on
photocopies for my lawsuit alone
yeah somebody in the chat just i went to
the er for a day it was 33k yeah no i
mean that's [ __ ] nuts yeah that
that's
yeah that's gotta be yeah people saying
after insurance yeah that's that's got
to be
just a fraction of the real cost wait
someone said jeff's a keemstar fan never
mind he deserved it it was his idea
take it all back best friendship delete
this episode yeah end the stream wait
hold on let me let me text my lawyer
never mind drop him
i don't know what that is but
yeah why why bring up the amount like
he's like listen i spent so much money
to help him
except for that stem cell there will go
halves fact that he's going around
saying i don't pay for surgeries like
that [ __ ] hurts like i want to nobody
says he didn't they truly do and like
right now he said he was late once and
then that [ __ ] his credit yeah he
never said he didn't pay for it word
like i told him that i pay for surgeries
he can still and and the reason
we haven't been it's important to break
that down because
david is conflating
an actual mistake he made
which is being laid on a payment with
something he's never been accused of
which is not paying his bills so it's
like it's a straw man he's he's
addressing an argument that was never
made that makes jeff look like a liar
which he never said
in paying for a surgery i don't know if
it's his assistant's fault or
or or jeff just told him to back off
from us but like i don't handle that
stuff more i just give approval to
suspend that whatever but like
natalie has asked multiple times like
loop us into all these surgeries and
we're just not getting looped into
anything yeah this is real interesting
because jeff says the total opposite
that he's been super persistent on them
all the time yeah and they're not
responsive and they're late that sounds
like
that sounds like somebody's assistant is
covering their ass and i'm more inclined
to believe jeff on this because
i mean i can see things falling through
the cracks on david's team
and i don't see why the person handling
this natalie because that's yes then
that becomes very believable because she
seems not it's
natalie and jeff even like i mentioned
earlier natalie was
kind of saying like rude comments and
email like oh what are you gonna do to
sue us [ __ ] like that
well
that's ultimately that'll get
figured out real quick if if uh he sues
him you know what i mean dude i really
want discovery and the the truth about
that little detail will come out so oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then and then
we're blindsided when he goes to another
surgery and then he'll like come out and
be like like his most recent surgery i
didn't know that he had a surgery until
you unfollowed me on instagram and
that's because you know it's a two-way
street we can be we can be like when's
your next surgery but also
we're not no one's looping us into what
we need to be paying for and to this day
like i'm still keeping my word like
i want him to send me whatever he needs
me to pay for like i will pay for it um
but it's just not fair to say
that we haven't been paying for it
because we
have paid literally every single bill
that has ever been paid yeah every bill
you didn't say they did it on time
yeah exactly on time questions because
they never said you didn't pay it again
yeah
not like throwing stuff out like that
definitely
dirty yeah start to dirty question the
framing of the whole thing
dirty [ __ ] bro
because he needs it
um
i don't know
this is
good you're you're speaking here this is
jason is so [ __ ] out of touch this
moment is just shocking your mind and
speaking your truth and your side of it
and it's good but at the end of the day
oh i thought that's where he goes i
think jeff is going to really like this
this is my favorite
yeah why is is everybody gone oh just a
b
we're all here okay hold it down
hi zach sorry
none of this
matters like nothing i say nothing he
says
nothing we say together will ever fix
what happened like that's the end of the
fact and like
and that's what sucks is like
it just can't be changed and it's a
[ __ ] really shitty accident and this
is a shitty [ __ ] time bro
it's just the thing that
i don't know i wish we could both figure
out
how to
approach he really should have just
thought about what he was going to say a
little more before recording i mean so
many of these just ends with
i don't know well i think he yeah i
agree and i think he was spending he's
been talking about this for a long time
it's circle jerking about it with
everyone who believes jeff's the bad guy
right and david's the good guy that when
he's on camera he's got to think of a
way to phrase it that doesn't make him
sound like a total lunatic
you know yeah there's like a massive
block party what is going on
yo can you just tell that that whole
block to turn it down maybe
oh she's going nuts party time i doubt
you guys can hear it though it's all
good moving forward like somebody else
did ikea deport back to sweden i don't
know what i'm saying no he's right i
honestly think he'll see this and this
is
jason you're so far gone bro
you're out
how to approach moving forward like
i don't know
actually i don't know what i'm saying
you know i i honestly think he'll see
this and
you know
really appreciate this
i think he will be
david's part of this is jeff going to
appreciate jason
how far up david's ass are you really
what even david's like
well david and natalie are both like
what because
i do she's like i do and jeff if you're
watching i i i i think that you will
appreciate this because i know he'll
appreciate this because
he um
i think he just feels unheard and he
feels like he was
swiped under the rock he feels unheard
therefore we need david to talk about it
for an hour
saying it was jeff's fault he's going to
love this
crazy crazy crazy take by jason there
ugg and stuff like that and
just just you talking about it for the
first time
pays a lot of credence to what happened
and it probably really helped with some
healing
what are you talking about it's funny
right after this drop jeff was like i
said i'm suing him i made up my mind can
you introduce me to some lawyers
i think it really helped
actually what i think would really help
is jeff's suing him and getting closure
through that so that he can actually
have
a ruling that says this is your [ __ ]
fault
you are liable
some things that we said that pissed him
off too
but i think it's really good right you
know it's it's a start were you
listening
and i don't really
care what the comments say i don't
really care what anyone has to say this
is all between us
and 400 000 people watching
what are you saying bro
you are [ __ ]
not making sense
i don't care what anyone says this is a
private conversation
that we posted on our podcast with 2
million subscribers
just saying hey were you listening
hey don't watch this video this is a
private conversation
hey you guys hey this is private turn it
off mute this
can't believe you guys are watching this
private moment
and we're doing this
so we all can heal and move on
and
ultimately hope things get better for
jeff too
yeah you know and this is our way of
doing it
you know
um i think it's also important to note
that just because this is the first time
that
this conversation is happening like
publicly for people to listen to doesn't
mean that it hasn't happened multiple
times in private yeah which is the
frustrating part of all of this is that
there have been
many conversations that cover all this
that's my least favorite too it's also
like really tough when
like i can see from just perspective
like it's probably really tough when he
sees my videos and i'm like traveling
the world and i'm having this like
[ __ ] time of my life and it's like
and he's getting his eye
cracked open yeah and it's like
and it totally looks like i haven't
mentioned this like no one can even
[ __ ] tell that i want to [ __ ] blow
my [ __ ] brains out yeah and and
dude i want to blow my brains out that
being said i'll go half on the brain
surgery
not made of money over here
that being said watch me uh
base jump off this building in dubai i'm
having the time of my life yeah
man i really want to kill myself anyway
i'm about to jump off the ti
the birds do whatever
[Music]
someone's the chat is saying jason also
needs the stem cell surgery
after that comment
and
and
that's part of the reason i want to do
this is like
this weighs on me
if
sorry but not to diminish his suffering
but again it's just
it's so short-sighted to make put
himself square in the victim place and i
really think the only reason david feels
that bad is because of what happened to
him i really don't think he cares about
jeff
or the essay victim and i think that
that becomes abundantly clear in casey
neistat's documentary
every [ __ ] minute of every day of my
life ah [ __ ] i'm so late
but like hey don't don't make don't ask
me to cry in your documentary if i'm
gonna cry i'll do it in my own video
i gotta get the juice
it won't
it won't mean as much in yours so like
it's [ __ ] you know he's crying for
himself right now he's not crying for
jeff he's not crying for hannah he's
crying for himself it's just so horrible
what happened to him it's like the worst
why are you crying
um no it's just i feel so bad no no
it was your fault you shouldn't left for
the bathroom um no
no no no that's so bad for you i feel so
bad for you man what the [ __ ] are we
doing here
he says i feel so bad for you
he really feels he's crying because he
feels so bad for david
that's just that's nuts no no no don't
do that yeah no i know and i feel bad
for jeff yes yes yes yes yes jeff jeff
jeff
right
and then after that
natalie
natalie who puts up with you and then i
feel bad for myself
welcome back love
not great not a great one eh
it was a big
love is back
so those meatballs were not authentic
you're telling me
i mean they i think they were kind of
authentic they they did have a little
bit of a weird taste
and that being said i did get some
swedish candy though some okay oh let's
go bring it here oh yeah my way i bought
i bought it yeah my favorite
dan is saying don't bring him the candy
not even one just one just one i can
throw it to you i mean if you catch it
okay bring it here
literally going over dan's right
literally
oh sure wait is that just a naked candy
no wrapping
wait it's not more of the salted
[ __ ] is it not it's only the good
[ __ ] i see i got
[Music]
i'm sorry about this they sell kit
swedish candy at ikea yeah i wasn't
surprised about that i got a whole
little
it's basically the swedish uh embassy
ikea oh my god he found how was i
supposed to catch it it wasn't a good
throw
it was way short i'm sorry to the fans
for for giving him the candy don't you
it was way short
just feel bad for you
all right well sorry about that ikea
failure we tried
um
anyways i think we still
i mean i kind of enjoyed the whole
debacle of
immediately getting yeah
yeah i know i mean we're still laughing
i'm mad it wasn't a photo total
and i got this ikea drip so
how many times can i tell you guys to
put the outfit on inside you know how
many times did i say that so maddie the
sam worked on it that was really cool in
its own
so wait we have more killed it so
amazing i disagree i think you it was
important to do the shot you guys did
okay we killed it though the
establishing shot was important yeah
mostly i just feel bad for david
david yeah he's the victim oh he's a
real victim in all this i still love you
though love we did buy uh like furniture
but i don't know you bought something
what'd you get
whatever the [ __ ] did you buy we were
supposed to build the building segment
right i wasn't sure if we were still
gonna do this i just bought like a shelf
how much was it
swedish dollar swedish coroner so what
is that um let's do it on next friday on
friday you can get to work on that
multiple times
we can get you in the ikea outfit and
time you assemble that sounds good okay
sure make the best of it that's great
[Music]
yeah i just feel bad for david
honestly
he's just been through so much yeah
he lost sponsors
i mean what compel
what compelled him to make this
because casey's documentaries right okay
okay that's fair right trying to spend
time ahead of that narrative yeah but
it's just not good like it just should
they're all in such a bubble
i mean it worked for i guess it worked
on the people that watched it at large
they're just
[Music]
they're gonna eat it up regardless
i think they'll come to regret this yeah
i agree
you got me that dog that can't take care
of
no but
i can't keep up with the man
no this [ __ ] this [ __ ] blows it
[ __ ] blows it's such a bad [ __ ]
situation and
and
and we've tried we've
we've had
this conversation like has happened with
jeff face to face
a good number of times i remember when
he was making the dock we went for a car
ride around and like
he was like hey i know you've apologized
to me person but like i want you to do
it on camera so people can see and i was
like okay so he rode around for 45
minutes and you know tears were shed and
there was a lot of conversating and
and he was really fair to me in the car
and we were really fair with each other
like it was very amicable and like it
was very sweet and we got back to the
house and uh and we recorded we didn't
hit record
on the camera really so we yeah it was
i'm not kidding it was beautiful he said
he forgives me he hugged me he kissed me
he told me he's not my fault whatsoever
he looked at the camera and said i
jeff whittake will never sue or hold
responsible david doberg my best friend
who i love so well it was my idea
and i take fifty percent of the blame
and then when we didn't hit record
oops
crap
i think it was like 45 minutes an hour
not hit record where's oscar and then
there you go and then we did it again we
were like let's go again so we went for
the same car ride down the same streets
talked about the same [ __ ]
um in the same way and like and that
never made it in to his video maybe it
was on his patreon i don't know where it
was but like
like
that kind of bummed me out it's like
we're having all these conversations and
like what is it for like do you need to
hear this from me or
it bummed me out that he didn't put that
in like what was he trying to do have a
real
conversation with me under the gui like
was he trying to trick me into actually
uh sounds like jeff wanted to record it
and even went and re-recorded it when it
but i love the insinuation is like i got
manipulated into actually spending time
with this guy
what was it for
what was it for
of course jeff doesn't have to include
anything it's his [ __ ] documentary
bro
you know
it sounds like that made me look really
good and he didn't include it
do you need to hear for your video or
like and no one's seeing it at the end
of the day it's like what is it for what
are we doing this for and like it
doesn't feel authentic you know
especially the second time
um
it's incredible that he's even given
saying this anecdote just trying to
paint jeff as some phony
so so yeah i don't know that's strange i
also
this is just like a really stupid like
little thing but like
the roast yeah he said that
he said jeff said somewhere that i cut
out i was cutting out jokes about myself
in the roast which is so not true
he only said one joke about me
and it was it was just about i didn't
even know he said a joke about me until
i asked jason i was like did you cut
anything out about me
and the joke was
um uh
david has a new show on discovery called
discovering david dobrik and
the only thing they're discovering there
is that david's gay
um
which is like good job i mean
yeah i mean that's it's a joke
quite often it's a joke yeah it's a joke
i'm sure i'm not uh not too sure about
myself but um
um no but yeah but we didn't try to cut
that better i would never
and that's what bummed me out it made it
seem like i'm controlling some edit here
and like taking out stuff about me i
definitely did not touch that [ __ ]
post nope not at all you didn't talk
about it
i think later for jeff it became more
like
he did okay whatever it's kind of boring
now
and one but if you guys want go over to
jeff
fm
and watch his response because it's good
okay um
definitely get a good perspective for it
here if you want the full
jeff story there
but yeah apparently jeff's gonna sue him
so that that actually could yield some
really interesting
um
evidence
depositions
there'll be a ruling i mean it's going
to be really interesting
[Laughter]
honestly that's the most interesting
thing that came out of today
let's be honest here
dude that's nuts
how long we've been going because we
have we have mom's basement
we're going for a long time really two
hours and 41 minutes wow having too much
fun oh you want me to watch this
specific
uh part here
uh jeff at which which highlight the one
you want me to watch
from jeff's video
okay uh from 3351
3351 of jeff's
goes he told me that
33
33.
here we go
i don't even give a [ __ ] because i know
this guy's a piece of [ __ ] but just
seeing jason
sit there and let him lie to him
and it's like bro these people just
don't give a [ __ ] about nothing but
money from
fame and clout from david that they're
willing to just sit there and let
anything happen you know i i honestly
think he'll see this and
i really appreciate this bro that's not
even the real jason that's him i think
he will because
i do
is this what you wanted me to say yeah i
do and jeff if you're watching natalie's
sick fake laugh you just ain't joking ah
maxwell
you [ __ ] gotta be kidding me they're
sitting there laughing like it's all a
[ __ ] look at her feels because
i know he'll appreciate this because
he um
i think he just feels unheard um i think
it's also important does he comment on
that any i mean i like what he said it's
not the real jason i don't know
just
he was replaced by a lizardoid
but i mean i think he does maybe a
little bit before this uh
let's
go watch jeff's yeah watch it okay
thank you
all right well
oh by the way we're speaking of that one
caller who was like jordan peterson is
not a homophobe and he doesn't support
conversion therapy you're just like
tucker carlson
i'm gonna save it for friday but that
man is a straight up convergent therapy
supporting homophobe yes he is he really
is
turns out i was more right than i
thought than i knew
so
uh
boy yeah we got all kinds of things
tomorrow so let's just call it a day we
got taco bell on the way
our troubles are over
that is a glorious thing david's however
are just beginning and i feel so bad for
him
my heart goes out today you're the
empath here
yeah i can't just feel so bad for david
i'm gonna cry for him
oh god
david
dan we had
we have so much good stuff yeah
tomorrow's our friday's gonna be a good
episode
like every time we're like not sure what
to talk about
these creators at like midnight are like
you know what we're going to keep your
ass up jeff said something funny to me
he's like i heard davis putting out a
podcast and if he does and he says he's
putting out podcasts blaming me and if
he does i'm going to put out a podcast
responding it so you should have a good
day tomorrow
you'll have an easy podcast
you're wrong on that one i said amen
brother thank you thank you jeff thank
you
all right that's it for today guys have
a good good week we'll see you on friday
make sure you hit that subscribe button
people subscribe they're dropping again
subscribe did you see that you know why
because we didn't say it it's not we've
been slacking dude we got to say in the
beginning it's not working it's working
we need to say or we need to we're i'm
kind of into the idea 100 above three
million smash
bros people are leaving i'm kind of into
the uh
i'm kind of into this whole back and
forth like i think it
i think it's kind of cool if we just
constantly are re-hitting no it's not
good no it's good because then we can
keep why is that good because we can
keep celebrating smash that like button
it's not a celebration
so many comments are like i've been
watching for years and i haven't
subscribed yeah well where are they i
say it every episode now we're only 216
above 3 million imagine where we'd be if
we didn't say it we'd be like it
true 2 million
yeah well maybe i won't have to [ __ ]
think about what a failure i have every
day
bringing up this stupid ass campaign to
beg people for subs for now i feel
pathetic and i'm still gonna drop below
we're just an ideas team out here you
know who cares about the subs the views
are good i didn't i didn't until these
guys
we talk about it every night actually
everyone have been screenshotting the
like button i've been liking those
tweets
i spent like 20 minutes doing that this
morning
on work time by the way it's not your
fault
don't you do this to me zach
it is your fault
i'm not
i'm robin williamson goodwill i'm
thinking if i was it is your fault well
it's not your fault
and people have been liking the uh the
calls too i've been saying the calls you
haven't even liking the haters
yeah i agree oh i find entertaining i
love it
especially when it ends wholesome you
want to add something dan
you said oh
oh whatever who cares
um were saying
nothing even says he doesn't care so
guys thanks for watching we'll be here
on friday we've got a great show lined
up it's gonna be a lot of fun so see you
then
be good stay blessed
and uh
h3 crew out
[Music]
you